Joining me today as an entrepreneur and
venture capitalist and author,
the Co founder of Paypal,
the first outside investor in facebook,
the founder of Palentier and Silicon
Valley's ultimate contrarian thinker
Peter Teal.
Finally,
welcome to the Rubin report.
David,
thanks for having me on the show.
It's good to be here with you.
I normally don't have this many cards
for a guest,
but,
uh,
I've got a lot of cards for you today.
Are you ready to roll?
Ready to go?
Alright.
So we have to start.
Obviously Rogan had allowed muskeg last
week,
last week,
and they smoked a joint.
So do you want me to put the joint on
the table right now or how are we doing
this?
You know,
my,
my number one rule is never to compete
with the.
I'll,
you know,
I would never,
I would never bet against Ilan.
Uh,
it's uh,
it's been like this,
uh,
I've been,
I was a close partner of visit paypal in
the,
uh,
in the late nineties,
early two thousands and uh,
and uh,
after pay pal,
you know,
Elon set out to start these two,
both the rocket company and the,
uh,
the uh,
electric car company,
space x and Tesla.
And I think the conventional wisdom on
Ilan was these were both completely
harebrained projects and if one of them
had succeeded that you have to sort of
question it.
And when both of them succeeded,
it's just that,
you know,
he knows something people,
other people don't.
All right,
well on that can be a matter of luck.
I'll keep,
I'll keep the joint right here for now
so I can compete with you on.
All right.
But let that,
that's a good place to start because
first,
you know,
it's interesting because we've gotten to
know each other a little bit in the last
couple of years and it seems to me that
the person that I know privately is sort
of different than the way the way the
media portrays you.
So I thought maybe at the beginning
let's just do a little history about you
and then we can get to some of the
controversies in some of the ideas that
you're really interested and things like
that.
So let's start with paypal since you
mentioned it already.
Where did the idea of paypal first come
from?
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's when,
when you start one of these companies,
uh,
it's,
it's typically not the case that you get
the whole idea fully formed,
you know,
instantaneously.
We certainly,
uh,
there was this incredible internet boom
going on in silicon valley in the late
nineties.
It felt that there was sort of this open
frontier,
open gold rush.
One of the natural things to look at
was,
was finance.
I was sort of very interested in the
cryptocurrency.
Could there be new forms of money?
And there's always something super,
uh,
a mysterious,
powerful,
important about money.
And it was,
it was,
it was the way that this was going to
change.
So we had,
I think we had this general idea to do
something with security,
with money,
with payments from very early on of the
founding of the company,
and then you iterate a lot on how to,
how to get the idea out and the,
the critical question for any consumer
internet product is always not what the
idea is,
but how do you get it out?
How do you get the distribution out?
And we spent,
there've been a of payments companies,
internet payments companies that have,
that are already started and failed by
1998.
There was one called one called a was
cyber cash through or you know,
the,
there's sort of a variety of these
different ones that have tried to create
these comprehensive currency schemes.
Um,
and they would work if everybody used
them,
but you can never get even the first
person to start at sort of the challenge
was how to make it viral.
How do you get something to work where
it's good for the first person,
for the 10th person to the hundredth
person in.
Once we have millions of people,
you have a network of network effects
and that was sort of the chicken and egg
problem.
How did you guys overcome that hurdle
where we eventually stumbled on this
idea of linking money with email because
there were ready 300 million people in
[inaudible],
99 that had email accounts and,
and so if you could send money to an
email address,
send it to your email and then you get
an email saying you've received cash and
then you'd obviously click on the links
and do the work necessary to get the
money out.
And so,
um,
and so you didn't need both counterpart
to a transaction to be part of the
paypal network.
Only the sender could be part of it.
And then the recipient,
the recipient would sign up as they took
the money out.
And uh,
and then we started with the 24 people
in our office.
Those were the first 24 customers and
they sent money to friends and to other
people.
We gave these referral bonuses.
We gave you $10.
You signed up and $10.
She got someone to sign up and it just
grew exponentially when we were,
you know,
it grew about seven to 10 percent
compounding daily and if you're,
you know,
an image to start with a small number,
if you get seven to 10 percent daily
compounding and after about a month,
year to thousand people by those mid
November of 99 by end of December of
[inaudible] 99,
it was a $12,000
by February third,
2000.
It was at 100,000
by mid April,
2000 goes up to a million.
And so.
So what did you do in terms of getting
people to understand the way you could
work with money differently?
Because I actually remember the first
time I used paypal,
I think it was in 2001 I was a
struggling comic.
I had moved into a roommates,
a little apartment because I didn't have
much money and I,
but I had to pay him a couple of hundred
bucks or something a month for a for
rent and he was going to give him a
check.
He said,
hey pal,
me and the,
just the idea that I was somehow linking
my bank account to something on the
computer.
We didn't even have,
I don't know if I'm not mistaken.
I think I was still using dialup.
I don't even know that we,
you know,
had,
had wifi or anything like that,
but it's about an idea that this can
even happen.
How did you train people to realize,
well,
it's always something that's real and
it's always on.
You normally serve to get people start
doing something like that.
It has to be something where there's an
intense need and um,
and maybe it's not too dangerous.
And so the know one of the natural
places that started was on the Ebay
auction site where small dollar
transactions,
maybe $40 with the typical amount.
And if you send chuck across the
country,
that's like a seven to 10 delay,
10 day delay.
It's slow.
Um,
most,
most people aren't set up to process
credit cards.
You roommate probably couldn't process
credit cards and so,
uh,
and so unit.
But since you could make paypal payments
with a credit card,
you could in fact send a credit card
payment to,
um,
300 million people,
whereas they're only something like
three or 4 million that are set up to
process a 150 million people with emails
in theU ,
s at the time and there may be $3
million that were set up to process
credit cards,
small businesses,
things like that.
So we expanded it by 147 million.
Do you remember what it felt like as it
started compounding the way you're
talking about?
Like what was that like as it was
growing and you realize like,
wow,
we really have this.
Well,
you are at the forefront of some sort of
revolutionary thing.
It,
it's incredibly exciting and it's
incredibly scary.
And it was a,
it was going to take over the world are
all going to die and move several times
between,
you know that those two,
several times a day.
Was there any bizarre pushback from
banks or any anyone that was doing
financial transactions?
Traditionally,
there were certainly like more than more
than our share of challenges.
You had a,
you had an enormous problem of fraud
where people just figured out ways to
hack the system and steal money and
then,
um,
and you can't simply get rid of fraud
because you always get flooded and make
it cumbersome.
If it's easy,
then it's also easy to defraud your
challenges.
How do you get it to be easy to use but
hard to defraud.
And that took,
it,
took some time there.
Um,
certainly a banks didn't like it,
you know,
the role of the incumbent players that,
that didn't like something new.
And then of course it was sort of in
this,
in this,
uh,
strange regulatory zone where it was a
new form of payments,
new form of moving money.
And uh,
and the,
the way I often thought of it at the
time was that we were in a race between
technology and politics and you know,
the politicians didn't like us,
but if we got the system,
the paypal network to be big enough,
it would sort of overwhelm the
regulators and they'd have to accept
that as a,
as a fait accompli.
So the Libertarian Party,
you must have love that concept,
like you were actually doing something
that libertarians are supposed to do
here.
There was a early 2000 conversation,
uh,
you know,
one of the,
one of the execs that paypal said that,
you know,
we need to hire a whole bunch of lawyers
elsewhere.
We what we can do or can't do it.
No,
we're not gonna hire them.
They'll tell us we can't do.
So we have to just go ahead and not hire
the lawyers and just just do it.
Now,
you know,
the sort of,
uh,
I,
I actually,
I do not know if a company like paypal
could have been started even two,
three years later.
So,
you know,
in the,
in the aftermath of nine slash 11,
we got the Patriot Act in the US and
that,
uh,
that attached,
you know,
much more regulatory scrutiny to,
uh,
to financial transactions,
to payments,
the know your customer rules became
much,
much trickier.
And so,
uh,
so I do think that there's a weird way
in which there was an opening to start a
business like paypal in 1999 slash 2000,
even three years later.
I think it might not have been possible.
Yeah.
And it's so cool to me just knowing a
lot of your ideology and the libertarian
ideas you care about and just going
ahead and building what you want to
build instead of waiting for other
people to do it.
I mean,
you actually did it and that's a pretty.
It's a pretty great thing.
Well,
it was,
um,
it was sort of the sense that,
you know,
we were going to change the world.
We're gonna,
you know,
give people more control over their
money.
We had all these ideas about,
you know,
getting rid of central banks and
creating a new currency.
We never quite got to the bitcoin stage
of it.
We'll get to that later.
But,
but certainly,
uh,
certainly these ideas were,
you know,
were incredibly motivational and doing
it.
And it is always a little bit of a
contrast from,
you know,
I always have this view on politics
where it's both incredibly important and
then in many ways incredibly frustrating
because it's so,
um,
it's like the air we breathe that
permeates our whole system and then it's
also so hard to,
to ever change,
you know,
as a,
as a college student,
I started you this,
a conservative Libertarian newspaper in
Stanford,
the Stanford Review and uh,
and there was a lot,
you know,
it's important to have debates to
discuss things and then it's often so
hard to,
to change things in the paypal hack was
in a way,
you know,
we were going to sign the world.
We're going to ask for permission.
We're just tech technology over
politics.
Well,
speaking of changing the world,
let's flash forward a couple of years.
So we're just doing some business
background first before we get to a lot
of your,
your ideas of the day.
You were the first outside investor in
facebook,
500 grand to the Zuckerberg guy.
Did you know him well before that?
Had you guys communicated a lot?
How did that even come to pass?
Not really.
Was the sort of actually literally the
first day we met,
we talked for an hour,
we came back and we gave him the term
sheet about an hour later.
So it was,
how was a,
it was a fast decision,
uh,
I think,
I think people always have this sort of
shark tank image of these things,
but some sort of super sophisticated
pitch and you say just the right things.
That's what works.
And it was nothing of the sort and he
was uh,
he was a,
you know,
kind of introverted 19 year old,
a sophomore between sophomore and junior
year,
summer,
summer of 2004.
And uh,
and um,
and the,
the main,
the main thing I had going for it was
just growing fast.
They were something like 20 college
campuses.
They had about 100,000
people on the network and they just
needed more money for computers because
there was such demand for,
for the product as they were going to
launch at more colleges in the fall.
So is that what appealed to you more
than the product itself?
Just that you saw engagement.
It was already,
it was already working.
Yeah.
Um,
and then,
but I would say the other,
the other part of it was that there was
like a prehistory to it.
So one of my,
one of my good friends from paypal back
from Stanford guy named Reid Hoffman who
started linkedin later years,
but uh,
and he worked with me at paypal in the
late nineties,
early two thousands.
But before that he had started a social
networking company back in 1997,
seven years before facebook.
And they had,
they already had,
um,
you know,
they had social net was the name of the
company.
So that social networking in the name of
the company seven years before.
And there were all these things that
they had,
they had thought about doing.
So it's going to be,
you know,
it was going to be your,
as the 19 nineties version of social
networking was going to have these
avatars and cyberspace and I might be a
cat and you might be a dog and I've been
virtual cat.
You're a virtual dog.
And we have to figure out how we relate.
And it turns out people aren't,
weren't really interested in that.
They weren't really interested in some
sort of fictional online persona.
It was much more about real identity.
And somehow facebook was the first one
to crack the problem of real identity
where even though it's always a little
bit curated,
certainly for the most part,
people on facebook are who they say they
are for the most part at least.
So am I mistaken,
you're the only person who's been on the
board of facebook the entire way out,
except for mark,
right?
Right,
right.
Since the beginning.
Yes.
Yeah.
Is,
what can I ask you about that,
that facebook won't get too angry about
if I asked you?
Well,
it just.
What's the experience like of being a
part of a board from the beginning of
really the thing of the Internet,
what seems to drive conversation the
most on the Internet?
Well,
there's um,
you know,
there's,
I mean it's been sort of like this
incredible trajectory,
you know,
uh,
where it's gotten probably much bigger
than I would have thought possible at
the time.
Even though I was,
I was incredibly optimistic and bullish
on it.
Certainly back in back in 2004,
2005.
I think that,
uh,
I think that one,
one kind of perspective for a lot of the
world class entrepreneurs is,
they're not specialists.
They're,
there's something close to poly maths.
So,
um,
you know,
if you have a conversation with Mark
Zuckerberg,
he'd be able to speak with a surprising
amount of understanding about a lot of
things.
We could speak about the details of the
facebook product.
He could talk about,
um,
the,
the way people think about social media,
the psychology,
the way the culture is shifting,
the management of the company,
his ideas on that,
his ideas on,
um,
and then how this fits into the bigger
history of technology.
And so it's a sort of an academic view
is often that you're like sort of a
narrow expert on one thing and that's
what you do and what it is about.
It's much more a sort of polymath like
intellect to understand all these
different things.
And the kinds of board conversations
we've had over the last 13,
14 years have just been this crazy
range.
Yeah.
It must be particularly interesting for
you though,
as sort of the outsider in silicon
valley and we're going to talk about
you,
why you moved down to La,
all that stuff
that you've been there the whole time,
that it's not,
you know,
they didn't for all the reasons that
silicon valley may be what it is.
You weren't ever booted off the board or
anything like that.
They've,
they've let you be the contrarian guy
there so that,
that actually must,
that's a good thing about silicon
valley,
I suppose,
or at least within the little microcosm
that you sit in,
right?
No,
I,
you know,
I don't experience,
a great deal of hostility to me
personally know people,
you know,
it's uh,
it's just,
uh,
you,
you always,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's sort of manifests in all sorts of
other ways.
So I do think Silicon Valley at this
point has a bit of a conformity problem.
It has a bit of a way in which people
are,
you know,
too,
too much all thinking the same way.
It's just like the apple.
I saw this meme on the Internet the
other day where it was sort of the
Silicon Valley in 1997 colon.
Think different in silicon valley.
Two thousand 18 colon think the same.
And uh,
and so there is something that's uh,
that's gone.
That's gone a bit wrong even though I'm
hard pressed to cite things where,
you know,
it's,
it's really affected me personally.
Yeah.
All right,
well I was actually going to push that
to a little bit later,
but let's just stay with that for now
then.
Do you remember moments,
did you see some markers along the way
where you realized some of this group
think was affecting the actual products?
Where were the actual ability to create
new technologies or new products where
that was actually causing stagnation?
Because I sent them,
I sent,
there's been sort of a long road to get
here,
but you have sort of been talking about
this for awhile now and I think there's
a direct connection to the diversity
myths,
which we'll also talk about what you
wrote 20 years ago.
Right?
Well,
I,
I do think Silicon Valley has shifted a
lot over over the years.
So when I was an undergraduate at
Stanford in the late 19 eighties,
Stanford was sort of a very liberal
politically correct place.
But these silicon valley surrounding,
uh,
not so much.
It was vaguely libertarian.
Uh,
you know,
it was,
it was a moderate Republican
congressional district and um,
and then sort of by the late nineties I
would say to shifted to being sort of a
moderate,
um,
moderate Democrat,
which is around the time I started
paypal.
Then if you fast forward another 20
years,
it's sort of,
it's,
it's sort of a pretty hard left.
Yeah.
So what there,
because it seems to me that if I was
taking the people that I wanted to be
the most creative,
the most outside of the box,
the most to look at the system and go,
how do we fix the system from the
outside?
You'd want a lot of libertarian
thinkers.
That's the way I would at least look at
it.
So you'd think that everyone in silicon
valley would be pretty libertarian.
They want to do things on their own.
And yet somehow in those 20 years it
became the opposite.
It's like you only ask the question to
why
is it,
why is it so so loved when I think these
things are,
you know,
they're,
they're somewhat over determined.
So I would say a part of it is,
um,
is,
uh,
it's probably the most educated part of
the country in terms of how much time
people spent in college.
And I think one of the downsides of too
much education is that you get the most
brainwashed.
And so it's,
it's,
it's the most educated can also mean
that it is,
it is the,
it is the most brainwashed,
uh,
you know,
um,
this is also true of the founders,
but certainly have many of the rank and
file people who are,
um,
if you're sort of like a really good
engineer or I'm really good at some
specific thing,
your education typically does not
involve you thinking that much about,
about politics.
And so it's not necessarily from deep
ideological conviction.
It's often more as a fashion statement
than,
as a question of,
of power.
So,
uh,
so one of the things that's always a
little bit hard to score is that even
though if you took a survey in silicon
valley,
it's,
it comes out as quite far to the left,
you know,
weirdly uniform.
We're sort of group think it's a super
hard to know where the people really
believe this,
whether they're,
whether they're just going along.
So I think it's pretty liberal,
but,
um,
but of course not as liberal as it
looks.
And that's way worse because it means
people are too scared to,
to articulate things.
There was a,
there was a dinner I had at my house a
week before the 2016 election with a
group of sort of center,
right?
Silicon Valley people.
One of them was a very prominent angel
investor in Silicon Valley and he said,
I'm a,
I'm voting for trump in a week,
but because I live in silicon valley,
I'm lying about it.
And so,
uh,
so are you saying this to you?
It was like 12,
12 people up there and you're like,
I'm the guy that just the convention,
he was honest about lying is unusual.
Is it a little bit unusual?
And,
and the way I is,
I tell people I'm voting for Gary
Johnson,
the libertarian,
so he couldn't,
he couldn't quite get away telling
people that it was voting for Hillary
Clinton because like,
your facial muscles wouldn't work.
And your alignment so small.
I,
Gary Johnson,
that was sort of what you,
what you could do.
And I think if you sort of looked at
what happened in the weeks before the
election,
Gary Johnson support sort of collapsed.
It all went to trump and the,
uh,
the question you have to ask is whether
those people just change their minds the
last minute or were they lying all along
or were they wanting to themselves?
And so I think the sort of political
correctness,
it's always bad for thought,
but it always makes things appear more
uniform than they are even in Silicon
Valley.
Yeah.
Well,
I think,
you know,
this,
I said I was going to vote for Gary
Johnson and I did vote for Gary Johnson
and as I always say,
I should be judged accordingly.
But here we are.
So this is actually a perfect segue then
to the diversity myth because 20 years
ago you're,
you're at Stanford and you saw a lot of
the problems that we are talking about
today.
Over and over again.
I told you a months ago,
I was listening on Cspan two,
a talk you gave about the diversity myth
and again,
it's from about,
I think at that point it was like 18
years ago or something and I was
listening to it and David walked into
the room and he said,
who is that talking?
Because it was all true and it was,
he thought it was somebody that he
thought I was listening to the news of
today,
like somebody's laying out what's going
on today,
but you saw this,
this issue with multiculturalism,
with fau diversity,
the focus on equality of outcome,
not opportunity.
You saw this way before seemingly anyone
did.
How,
how did that come to be?
Well,
it was,
um,
there was certainly.
I'm quite a wave of the stuff in the
late eighties,
early nineties on,
you know,
a number of college campuses and for a
variety of reasons,
um,
you know,
a lot of it crystallized at Stanford.
There was a,
there was this,
there was this super intense debate
about a western culture which was both a
freshman,
one year long freshmen sort of general
humanities course where you learned
about,
you know,
western culture history,
Western civilization.
But then it was a course and the,
and the research,
Jesse Jackson showed up to campus one
day and sort of blood this chant,
hey,
Ho,
western culture has got to go.
And people were talking about both the
course and of course,
the whole society and culture that was
represented by that and,
uh,
and,
and so there were a lot of these
different debates that got a got sort of
thrown up.
So is concerned about discriminate
racial discrimination,
gender discrimination,
you know,
other kinds of people who were
victimized.
Uh,
and then,
um,
and then in many cases it felt like it
was this incredible overreach where
people were in some sense using their
victim status as a stick with which to
beat other people up or something like
that.
Or we're going to victimize the
victimizers and it's going to be sort of
a,
something like that.
And,
uh,
and so multiculturalism and political
correctness where somehow I'm very
linked.
The multiculturalism part was we're
gonna give special privileges.
Um,
you know,
to disadvantaged people are in,
some are correct.
These injustices of the past and the
politically,
the intolerant politically correct part
was we were going to go after their
oppressors whether they were real or
imagined.
And,
uh,
and in many ways it felt like,
you know,
incredible overreach.
You ended up with,
uh,
with these draconian speech codes on
campus,
um,
and,
and with,
with sort of the humanities in a sense
effectively got gutted in the late
eighties at Stanford though,
of course,
it took many years for that to,
to,
to fully play out.
But,
uh,
and then of course,
one of the buzzwords then as now was
diversity,
which,
um,
uh,
and,
and you know,
I think,
I think diversity is a good thing.
I think especially,
you know,
diversity of ideas is,
is,
is to be valued,
but you don't have real diversity.
You just have a group of people who
looked different and uh,
and think alike.
And so it's,
it's,
it has to meet,
it has to be more than just a,
you know,
then just,
um,
having the extras from the space cantina
scene worse or something like that.
Right.
And,
uh,
and that's.
And so that's always,
that's always.
So it's always like an internal
critique.
The diversity method is that it's not
about diversity at all.
It's about,
it's about conformity.
Was that the first time that you had
really staked out what is seemingly an
unpopular position?
Although I think actually,
especially in 2018 is,
is quite a popular position,
even if it's thought of as,
as out there was that the first time you
would publicly,
because nobody wants to be the guy that
says this stuff and then immediately is
going to be called a racist and a bigot
and a homophobia.
All those things.
Had you ever done anything like that
before?
You know,
it's,
it's uh,
you know,
I probably,
and it's,
it's hard to know how far to go back in
the autobiographical history or how good
I am at this,
but,
but probably already in a junior high
school,
high school,
I would,
um,
you know,
I would take the positions that I
believed in and they wouldn't,
they wouldn't necessarily be the
majority of positions.
And so it was,
you know,
it,
in junior high school I was totally
against struggle legalization of any
sort and that was a minority.
That was a minority view or A.
I supported Reagan in 1980.
And,
you know,
we were sort of in a relatively liberal
area and that was against sort of a
minority view.
So,
so I think I would have had a w,
I wouldn't say like extreme outlier
positions,
but,
uh,
but I,
I've,
I've always thought that it was
important to think for yourself.
So when you wrote the book and then
started talking about these issues,
what kind of pushback did you get?
Because that I think is the core issue
that most of my viewers are identifying
with these days,
that they're taking positions that are
true,
that don't mean that they're racist or
bigots or homophobes,
but that they mean they care about more
about diversity of ideas then diversity
of skin color or those things.
And,
and they're scared to say those ideas.
And yet you were doing it a long time
ago.
Well,
it's,
uh,
it's always,
it's always a very tricky thing.
So it's,
it's,
um,
on some level,
I'm on some level the way we've just
been talking about it,
there aren't that many people who will,
who will go out of their way to disagree
with us.
So people know you,
you don't want people.
I mean,
there's some people,
but most people would say find out.
No we don't,
we,
we don't want any different views are,
you know,
we need to suppress views.
People.
Some people say that,
but not,
not really that many.
Well,
they mask it in other ways,
right?
No one's going to outright say then.
But then in practice you end up with
this,
uh,
with this,
with this incredible conformity,
even though that's not in theory with
people.
Would people want.
One of the,
one of the professors I studied under
stanford is Rene Girard,
is for a cultural critic.
Philosopher a literary theorist is
really brilliant guy.
And he sort of always had this theory
that people imitate each other.
They copy each other,
they're sort of,
they're much more prone to fashion and
things like this.
And uh,
one of them he was,
he was from France.
And so one of the,
one of the metaphors he had for a lot of
the sort of more politically correct
professors at Stanford was that they all
thought they were in the French
resistance,
but,
but if they had lived in vichy France,
they would have all been collaborators
and um,
and,
and so the,
the,
the self understanding people have is
that they're super courageous,
independent thinkers and that's why they
[inaudible] that they would have been in
the resistance in France.
But then in reality,
if you ask them what the views are that
they have,
it's the same as everybody else around
them.
Yeah.
Well,
that.
And you have to always ask if everyone
has the same views.
It can mean one of two things.
It can mean that you've reached the
absolute truth or it can mean that,
uh,
that you have a,
you have this sort of incredible
conformity.
Yeah.
Well,
it's so interesting
because he was talking about the
resistance in France and now we have a
group of people in America that think
that they're part of the resistance.
And I suspect that if they were in
power,
they would be treating the people who
were the resistance of them much worse
than they're being treated.
Right.
Well,
I,
I've thought that the,
the reward critique could also apply to
them that,
uh,
that,
you know,
by identifying yourself as part of some
mob like resistance movement,
you're suggesting the exact opposite.
That,
uh,
you know,
it counts,
political views,
you know,
I respect,
uh,
you know,
I think there are people can have
sincere views even if they're in the
overwhelming majority,
but it's,
it's impressive if you're in the
minority.
So if you're,
if you're speaking out against president
trump in your small town in Alabama,
I tend to think that if you're,
if you're in,
if you're in San Francisco or Manhattan,
um,
and uh,
and you're,
you're part of the resistance,
I suspect something very different is
going on.
That's really interesting to me.
Like a different way of getting at this
is a,
you know,
in a democracy,
we always think the majority is right.
So it's 51,
49,
51 probably,
right.
If it's a big majority,
it's even more,
right,
so 70 slash 30 even even more,
right?
But if it's 100 to zero,
99 to one,
that's uh,
that's where we start to suspect that
we're not a democracy,
but we're in North Korea or that
something's gone wrong with them voting
machine or something like this.
And so when we have these sort of
hothouse environments at places like
Stanford or,
uh,
or silicon valley where you have this
complete uniformity of thought,
the thing you have to suspect,
this is not the wisdom of crowds.
It's not that everyone's figured out the
truth,
it's a madness of crowds.
It some psychosocial insanity.
Yeah.
And this seems to be directly linked to
what's going on on our campuses today,
right?
I mean,
if,
if 20 years ago you had been thinking
these things,
do you think your prediction would have
been,
oh,
we'll be able to break these ideas
enough so that the,
the class of teachers and professors may
not be so addicted to it seems to have
come back with a vengeance on oncology
or even even,
you know,
radicalized further.
But,
uh,
but again,
it,
it's uh,
you know,
this is sort of like,
it's,
it's a,
it's a subtle,
you know,
you don't want always psychologize
people you disagree with,
but the,
the question when you look at what's
happening on campuses or in various
places is always,
is this really what people think or is
it just,
are they just under,
you know,
incredible peer pressure to fit in?
Yeah.
Do you see that as a bizarre direct
connection to the way many other
institutions seem to be crumbling now?
The way people don't trust the media the
way they used to,
the way that we're just seeing sort of a
new,
you know,
alon on Rogan last week.
You're sitting here today the way that
people want different conversations.
We're going to sit here for as long as
it takes to do all the people can see
through it.
They can,
they can see through,
um,
the manufactured consent.
They can see,
they can,
you know,
it's,
if you have conformity and it,
and it looks real,
that's powerful.
If it,
if it's conformity and people sense that
it's forced,
that's,
that's a lot shakier.
And so there's,
it's sort of like,
I don't know,
it's like the,
I'm not sure what the right metaphor is,
but it's like maybe,
maybe it's like the wizard of Oz where
you have the man behind the curtain and
we're looking at the man behind the
curtain on the Internet and uh,
and that it doesn't quite work and you
know,
our,
I think our sort of media political
machine,
maybe it,
maybe it always worked when people
didn't understand how it works.
And so if you sort of see what's going
on in sausage making factory,
you know,
you might not want to eat as much
sausage anymore.
Yeah.
All right,
well this is clearly going to be a theme
to almost everything else we talk about.
So let's,
let's sort of catch up to where you are
today and then we're going to go back to
some of that stuff.
Tell me a little bit about pallet here.
Well,
this was a,
this was another company I started,
uh,
in,
in 2004.
Uh,
it was,
um,
sort of the big picture,
the big picture of pay pal was sort of
revolutionized money and payments,
the big picture for pound Chins,
sort of like in the wake of nine slash
11,
a few years after that was could one do
something from a libertarian or civil
liberties point of view that would still
be tough on terrorism and uh,
and,
and things like this.
And um,
and the,
the sort of a sort of sense I had was
that,
uh,
that uh,
the way we were going with just,
you know,
ridiculous airport security checks and
super intrusive surveillance all the
time.
It wasn't really making us safer.
So this was sort of your answer to the
Patriot Act in a way.
In a way this was sort of like,
I know you,
you had the ridiculous
lines at airports.
He'd been through all the ways that,
uh,
you know,
the response,
um,
and,
uh,
and it was,
and there was a question,
was there some way,
was there some technological fix?
And,
you know,
one of the ways I often think of
technology is that it's a way to do more
with less and um,
and so,
you know,
you can,
um,
you can get,
you know,
you can get more energy for less money.
That's like an energy innovation or
cleaner energy for less pollution,
um,
more energy that pollutes less.
That would be like a technical or
technology innovation and clean energy.
And in the security space,
the doing more with less is something
like,
um,
is something like more security with
less intrusion on people's civil
liberties.
And that's kind of the,
that's kind of the tradeoff that you
want.
And that the non non-technological
debate that we had in the U,
s and 2004 in any ways that we still
have in 2018 is,
is always,
uh,
it's always,
you do more with more versus less with
less.
And so you can have the,
um,
the neo-con I'm Cheney version,
let's say,
would be that we're going to have,
you know,
we're going to have more security with
more civil liberties violations.
And then you can sort of say that they
equally,
luddite a clu would say something like,
we're going to have fewer civil
liberties violations and we're going to
have less security.
And,
um,
and that's kind of the way the
ideological debate gets framed.
Now I am sympathetic to the Hclu on
civil liberties,
but I think they will always lose that
debate because,
uh,
the way you preserve civil liberties is
not to have terrorist attacks because
when you get a terrorist attack,
you get the Patriot Act.
And you know,
if the World Trade Center would erode
civil liberties as much as it did in
2001,
I didn't even want to think what would
happen if you had another terrorist
attack.
And so you have to prevent it to,
uh,
to stop,
to stop erosion.
What pound here does is,
uh,
is,
um,
it,
it sort of is a way for,
um,
for,
uh,
for know patterns and data to be
visualized through a combination of
computers and human analysts.
And,
um,
and then,
and then in a way that doesn't simply
scour the planet and get all the
information that everybody.
So it's just if there's something
suspicious then you look some more and
so there's sort of a,
there's a natural product you build
before you investigate people and in
that sense it's,
it's way less intrusive.
Is this a tough position to hold just
because people theme all too eager to
give up their civil liberties.
Like we always want easy answers.
So that's why I think the Patriot Act
passed with two dissenting votes,
if I'm not mistaken,
that people don't really react so
emotionally all the time.
And especially after a time like
September 11th,
we were really,
I think out of whack individually and
collectively that you can come in with a
more sane answer and say,
I understand civil liberties and I don't
want big government,
but I want us all to be safe and that
that's almost doesn't ring for people
because they just want the easy answer.
They want the bumper sticker answer.
Yes,
yes.
I,
I think it's,
it's not the easiest sell,
but uh,
but I,
I think there is certainly a lot more
awareness today about how much civil
rights have been eroded.
You know,
how we're living in a surveillance state
all the time and how,
you know,
deeply uncomfortable that is on,
on,
on so many levels.
I think that,
uh,
I think that uh,
the way,
um,
you know,
I think certainly if it worked,
if the,
if the luddite heavy handed approaches
actually worked,
then I think people,
people would be more tolerant and then
there's sort of a sense that they,
they don't even,
they don't even work.
Is it hard to define what work even
means because something could say work
for three years,
make sure everybody's safe even if it's
violating all sorts of personal privacy
and all that.
But then if there's an attack then you
go,
well it doesn't work,
but what work means you prevent
terrorist attacks from happening in the,
in the narrow,
narrow.
So it's just about the,
the window that it works basically
because the second it doesn't work,
it doesn't work and well it's,
it's a,
it's how many you prevent that would
have otherwise happened.
Yeah.
So I mean it's,
it's,
it.
Maybe if it works perfectly friend,
all of them,
if it works pretty well,
prevents most,
something like that.
So this must be a little bit of a tricky
situation for you because you obviously
have to work with the government on some
of this stuff.
Right?
And I'm sure that that's probably not
thrilling for you at some level.
Well,
I,
look,
I believe that,
uh,
it's,
you know,
I,
I believe you can be both a libertarian
and uh,
and,
and work with the government or even
work for the government or work in the
government,
uh,
and uh,
and even,
even if you believe that there should be
a much smaller,
much less intrusive government,
you can still try to work to make it
function better.
And so there's both an outside and
inside game.
Yeah.
Know there's all these versions like
this.
So it's like if you're a libertarian,
should you refuse to take a social
security check and a,
well you can be against social security
and still personally collect a check.
I'm pretty sure I ran to security.
If you're,
you know,
if you're a libertarian,
should you refuse to be a public school
teacher because you're a,
the government,
well maybe,
maybe it's actually better to be a
public school teacher rather than some
socialist,
a person who will otherwise get it up by
default.
So,
so I,
I think,
uh,
I think we can,
we can have certain kinds of principles
and then,
and then act and pragmatic ways and this
isn't necessarily hypocrisy.
You once said to me,
and I'm sure you've said it to other
people,
that I wouldn't be a libertarian if it
worked.
Do you sort of picture a moment or do
you remember a moment where you think
it,
I guess basically big government stopped
working because it didn't work for
awhile,
basically,
right?
Not,
not in our lifetimes,
not are not very well in our lifetimes.
I would say,
uh,
it's,
it's easier to see with,
uh,
with,
with the benefit of hindsight.
But I think,
uh,
yeah,
I used to think,
you know,
when I,
when I was in college in the 19
eighties,
I used to think that libertarianism was
a timeless and eternal thing.
It was just these absolute truths for
all time,
all places in all times.
And I've,
I've now come to think that it's,
it can be sort of,
there are certain contexts where it's
more true or less true.
And so if you have,
if you have incredibly well functioning
government,
political institutions are sort of less
of a need for libertarianism in the 19
fifties or 19 sixties when a state of
California had first rate public schools
across the board.
Um,
and if you said,
well,
the government can't do anything in the
public,
schools can't work.
It might have been problems with them,
but that argument has gotten a lot less
traction than it would today in 2018.
Right.
Because you would be the utopian person
at that point,
right?
Yeah.
Or You'd be,
you'd be,
you'd be too pessimistic because
obviously things,
things,
things weren't that,
of course your theory on that.
And,
and certainly,
um,
or in the military context we had a,
we had the,
uh,
the,
um,
the atom bomb,
we had the Manhattan project,
we had the Apollo space program in the
19 sixties where you've got a man on the
moon.
So if you said government can't do
anything that,
uh,
that,
that felt somewhat wrong.
Now I now I think,
I think the thing if we were on us,
and this is always the,
you know,
somewhat disturbing thing is that our
government works much less well than it
used to.
Um,
you know,
I think so that's my question.
Do you do look at a moment where that.
Yes,
yes.
I think libertarianism started probably
failing in the 19 seventies,
uh,
in a serious way maybe really building
up in various ways.
But uh,
and,
and libertarianism,
the Libertarian party in the US started
in the early seventies and it sort of
makes sense because there was sort of
more of an opening and so it was more
true then than it had been before.
And I would argue that it is,
it is much more true in 2018 than it was
30 years,
30 years ago,
you know,
the,
um,
you know,
when the books were written in the 19
fifties,
it was like,
it felt like it was crazy when I first
weeks it was like so bleak,
so pessimistic things were so,
so,
so busted,
so broken when I first read them in like
the late eighties,
it,
it still felt pretty crazy,
you know.
And then the last decade,
it's in many ways felt in a much more
correct.
There was,
you know,
there's a,
in atlas shrugged,
they're trying to find who,
you know,
who is John Galt the clues eventually
take them to the state where everything
has gone haywire.
It's the state of Michigan.
And uh,
there's this great company,
the 20th century American Motor Company
was sort of a thinly disguised general
motors that had just gone bankrupt.
And it was because we'd be completely
mismanaged along these sort of socialist
kinds of principles.
And Detroit was sort of falling apart.
Some was farming in the middle of the
city.
And uh,
and this was like 1957,
was just sort of a crazy thing.
And then it's,
it's,
it's disturbingly more true today.
Yeah.
Well,
you're on brook who used to be the head
of,
uh,
Ari and I ran institute who I've had on
the show many times and I do some
speaking events with.
He always tells me that when he travels
internationally now that it's the
countries that are sort of worse off at
the moment that are just trying to reset
that,
find those ideas the most interesting
because they're just desperate for
ideas.
So in a way,
it almost sounds like you're calling
libertarianism almost a course
correction for when either capitalism or
not necessary capitalism for when big
government just gets out of control.
Libertarian can come in,
libertarianism can come in and kind of.
Well that's the,
that's the hope.
I mean certainly,
um,
uh,
a lot of these sort of bad bro,
we're chronic things don't,
don't self correct that much and it is
probably very hard for there to be
incremental reform from within.
And that's why something like sort of a
libertarian shock therapy,
maybe maybe what you actually maybe what
you actually need.
Um,
but uh,
but yeah,
no one way to think about what,
what's happened in the US is you had,
you had sort of institutions set up and
then over time they sort of ossified and
degraded.
So when NASA was started in the 19
fifties,
you had no great scientists that were
driven,
motivated and then eventually it became
sort of more and more bureaucratic and
somehow the politics replaced the
science and we can't reset it or
something like this.
I think something like this happens by
the way in a lot of the private sector
where you know,
big companies become bureaucratic and
less functional.
But in the private sector you can have
new companies get started and if big
companies are too badly run,
they go broke.
And in the government thing for
government to go broke,
it has to be incredibly bad.
And the,
and the tricky question is always how do
you course correct before you get there?
Right?
So do you have a general prescription
for how government and private
enterprise can work together?
Is there a general view on when it is?
Right.
That seems to be what a lot of people
are talking about right now because I do
sense that there is a,
as I would call it,
sort of a classical liberal movement
happening right now or libertarian
movement and the question always is well
when men is the right moment for
government to do more or less,
depending on which way you look at it.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know if I have a sort of
formulaic general answer money.
My,
my ideological biases,
libertarian is that we should have a
smaller government that's less
intrusive,
less regulatory,
mostly across the board.
I don't think I have to tell you exactly
how small it should be.
It should just be,
it should do less,
you know,
we don't have to talk about,
do we have to privatized roads or you
know,
all this sort of crazy drivers license.
I don't want to set all the boundaries.
We know we have,
there's a lot of,
lot of room to go,
a big picture,
and then I think in terms of the
details,
there are of course always these ways
that you can try to reform things,
try to make things work better,
uh,
recognizing that you often have no super
entrenched bureaucracy.
So if you can shift from public schools
to charter schools,
that's sort of a way to change the
bureaucracy.
If you could,
if you could shift things where you
could,
um,
you could fire people or you could shut
down agencies that would probably reform
things quite a bit even though that's,
that's seemingly a very hard lift.
Yeah.
So I wanted to hold trump a little bit
longer,
but I feel like this is the right segue
because there's an interesting piece of
trump that I think a lot of people,
a lot of libertarians are happy with
when it comes to cutting taxes,
cutting regulation,
which has done a ton of,
and a few other things in that regard.
And then on the other hand,
it seems that there is a piece of him
that's more than happy to do as many
things by executive action as they'll
allow him to do.
And maybe in some cases he would try to
do things that they wouldn't allow him
to do.
So you supported the guy.
So let's just start there.
When,
when it was bubbling up in your head
that you were going to support him or at
least,
or get you,
gave his campaign money,
all of that,
what kind of internal discussions were
you having with yourself or were you
having it with friends and,
and colleagues and things like that?
Well,
um,
well,
the,
uh,
one of the things that,
that I would say was,
is I think super important issue for me
and,
and I think should be for libertarians
generally is his foreign policy.
And I believe that the US should have a
less interventionist foreign policy.
I believe that we've gotten into too
many stupid wars,
um,
over the years.
Um,
and that,
uh,
you know,
that sort of,
these questions of if the government can
kill you or in the sort of like,
that's maybe one of the most intrusive
forms of government I think really hard
about,
you know,
how often we do that and um,
and that there was some,
there was some need to,
to reset that.
And I think,
uh,
and so if you,
from my point of view,
if you,
if you got someone who's not great on a
lot of issues but was libertarian on
foreign policy,
that would count for a lot and if you
had one who's good on a lot of other
issues but bad on foreign policy,
um,
that would actually eroded in a lot of
ways.
And I think the Bush 43 administration
who was also sort of lower tax
anti-regulatory,
but then because you had the insane war
in Iraq,
um,
and you had to have all these deficits
than you do congressional log rolling.
And so then you end up with no child
left behind.
You end up with the Medicare part d,
the whole,
you know,
the,
all the sort of crazy expansion of,
um,
of the welfare state as part of the log
rolling exercise for,
for the,
for the foreign wars.
And so if we're going to do the anti
Bush 43 and I actually have a smaller
government,
maybe the sort of our committee Dan
Lever for moving that is foreign policy
and is for us to be,
uh,
to be less engaged.
And I think that that is,
um,
you know,
and it,
it,
it was,
and this was,
this was the place where we're.
Trump broke the most sharply from a
Republican Orthodoxy in the primaries.
You know,
the person who is sort of most opposed
to Jeb Bush who is somehow represented
in just a continuation of,
of the war strategy,
had these devastating questions like,
you know,
was,
was the Iraq war a bad idea.
And Jeb had never thought about it.
And um,
and it was an,
they had never thought about it because
you had this Washington dc.
I'm pro war foreign policy bubble and it
was Clinton's,
the bushes,
Obama.
And maybe moderated a little bit,
but still got pulled into Syria.
We sort of messed up Libya even more
than it had been before.
And uh,
and uh,
and,
and I think trump represented a really
big break.
I gave,
I gave to a.
did,
you know,
I spoke at the convention in Twenty
Sixteen and then I'm also spoken in the
fall at the,
uh,
at the Washington Press Club in both
speeches.
I,
I stressed this foreign policy theme,
so it was,
uh,
it was that,
you know,
should we,
should the US really be,
you know,
how aggressively should the US be
involved in Syria and risk a
confrontation with,
uh,
with,
with Russia.
And I think trump's instincts continue
to be,
you know,
much less in this,
in this sort of super power
confrontation.
And if you,
if you look at where the opposition to
president trump comes from,
the sort of,
the most deranged part of it is from the
neoconservative Republicans because this
is where he's broken the most with
orthodoxy.
We have Russia debate is a completely
insane,
the bank that we have like this where,
you know,
I think trump has been consistent for 30
years.
We should not have,
even if Putin's and man,
it doesn't mean that we should be
risking a nuclear war with Russia sort
of bag used to be a position of the left
by the way recently as 2012 when,
you know,
when Romney was hawkish on Russia and
Obama said the eighties or calling and
this is like.
And then so there's something about it
that's just incredibly crazy how tribal
it is.
Well,
it's so interesting because that moment
in the debate between Romney and Obama,
if the left was being consistent about
this,
they'd be looking at Obama now and
going,
man,
you must have been the worst president
of all time because you misjudged that.
And then that led us to our Russian
puppet president or something.
But you don't see that side.
You don't see that sort of consistency
at anyone these days.
I suppose it feels incredibly deranged.
But,
uh,
but certainly the intuition is that,
we shouldn't be this fixated on
escalating,
escalating these potentially military
complex with,
with places like Russia and,
and to the extent we have that as,
as the focus,
it distracts us from,
from a lot of other things to distracts
us from the very real economic
competition we have with China and which
I think is something we should be taking
more seriously.
And then of course even more importantly
maybe distracts us from mom from are
solving some of the problems at home.
So I do think,
you know,
the foreign having a less aggressive
foreign policy,
that's maybe the preliminary step to
getting to then really fixing on solving
our own problems.
Does that show you how,
how derange the conversation has gotten?
Because if you listen to conventional
thinking on this,
most of,
I think trump's critics will say,
look,
he's saying all these things about North
Korea or he's making all these threats
about Syria or we drop the mother of all
bombs or all of these things.
But you're actually making the reverse
argument.
I mean,
they're trying to argue that he's really
the warmonger,
he's the one that's going to lead us to
a world war three.
And really your argument is he's the one
doing the reverse of those things,
at least for now.
Yes.
I mean,
look,
I think,
I think there is.
We have a certain type of military
industrial complex and so there are
parts of this that are sort of almost on
autopilot,
but,
uh,
but certainly I think all of president
trump's instincts are to,
you know,
it's like,
if,
um,
we have to rethink NATO,
we have to rethink,
you know,
how much we should really be committed
to Afghanistan.
We have to,
you know,
we shouldn't be escalating like crazy
with,
with Russia.
And so,
um,
you know,
you have the North Korea dictators a
genocidal maniac,
but we'll talk to him.
So I think the instincts are,
um,
are,
are very powerfully in the,
uh,
deescalate Tory side.
What is it about trump that made you
think this is the guy could do that
because we,
as I was hearing you say that you could
have said,
well,
Ron Rand Paul,
he's doing a pretty good job on that
stuff,
right?
He's been talking about getting out of
these wars for a long time.
Like you could have been.
Even when I would watch the debates,
I'd be like this poor guy.
He's on the stage with the wrong group
of people.
He's making a lot of sense to me.
Uh,
but I support it.
You know,
I did support Ron Paul,
Ron Paul in both 2008 and 2012.
I think that,
uh,
you know,
I think in some ways a,
um,
ran.
Paul was sort of making those arguments
will.
I actually think trump made them more
powerfully in the 2015 slash 2016
primaries than even even a rand Paul.
And to critique rand Paul a little bit
on this hit,
it was sort of,
he was sort of making this judgment call
that his dad hadn't been able to get
enough boats.
And so he got to be a little bit,
uh,
less dubbish on foreign policy,
had to be a little bit more agreeable
and of course he didn't end up doing
much less well than his dad because he
sort of in a way downplayed what
might've been in one of his best issues.
And then,
and then trump just articulated far more
powerfully.
So what is that x factor thing with
trump?
Because obviously this was starting to
be like a runaway train and the,
all the momentum was there.
All the media attention was there.
It takes us back to the beginning of
when we sat down the way you described
paypal when it started really getting
into that growth phase.
So you must've seen that too.
And thought,
all right,
the right ideas are kind of here.
But really what I'm seeing is it's,
well,
there's,
you're at least talking about some
things you're talking about some of the
important substantive things that we
should be talking about.
And,
uh,
and uh,
you know,
part of,
again,
part of the negative part is that it's a
contrast to how bad and a lot of the
other people were.
I met a number of the different
Republican candidates running in 2016
and a small one on one meetings and I
think they're like zombies,
you know,
and it was just,
you had to do.
So the ideological talking points,
um,
it was sort of not fluid,
very hard to,
um,
to,
get off script to,
to say anything and um,
and that somehow wasn't,
wasn't quite what was called for.
And of course,
you know,
there was something else about Hillary
Clinton that was very much like this.
And uh,
and I think,
you know,
I think the revisionist history people
like to now say is that Hillary Clinton
was this terrible candidate.
And I,
I think,
I think she was,
she was the best candidate the
establishment could put up.
Um,
it was just,
the ideas were wrong.
That didn't make sense.
You know,
Hillary Clinton thinks she should run
again in 20,
20.
And in a way she's right.
Because from her point of view,
I understand why she thinks that because
she's smarter than the other Democrats,
she has more experience and you know,
within the Zombie Establishment,
um,
it still makes more sense for it to be
hillary than someone like cory booker,
Kamala Harris.
But the ideas are just,
the ideas would just become,
you know,
completely ossified.
What does it say about sort of the state
of the West that when things are,
are basically pretty good,
not to say they're perfect,
but basically pretty good that there's
always this feeling that the
establishment has to be destroyed or
washed away.
Well,
um,
well we,
there's,
well that's a big question,
but I think there's something that goes
back in our,
you know,
we,
we are,
you know,
there's something about western Western
civilization that is,
it is perhaps unique is sort of like,
it's open,
it's,
it's self referential,
self critical.
And so,
um,
and so,
uh,
and,
and you don't have the sort of internal
self criticism and in other societies
and other cultures.
And so,
you know,
there's always,
there's always an argument that,
you know,
ours is an extra stream,
really racist,
sexist society discriminates and all
kinds of ways.
And um,
you know,
without challenging that for now,
um,
you can also say that ours is a society
that cares a lot about racism,
sex,
and the cares a lot about injustices
that the ways things are not working.
And so I think,
um,
and so I think the establishment is not
gotten a free pass in our society for a,
for a very long time.
And that's,
and you can say that's,
that's unhealthy and it makes us weak or
divided.
But,
uh,
but I think it's,
it's a,
it's part of the motor that drives our,
our civilization.
And,
you know,
maybe it,
maybe it goes back to,
you know,
in sort of the enlightenment or the
renaissance or um,
you know,
the Greco Roman or Judeo Christian
traditions.
But,
uh,
when,
when Jesus Christ says that he's the son
of God,
um,
you know,
you can,
you can describe that as a metaphysical
religious statement,
but you can also describe it as a
politically atheist statement because
Caesar Augustus was the emperor and
Cesar has sort of adopted father,
had been divinized Caesar.
Augustus also claimed to be the son of
God.
And when Jesus Christ says that he's the
son of God,
that is a challenge.
The establishment.
That's an act of political atheism.
It's the state is not divine.
The establishment is not divine.
And that I think that's,
that's just,
that's just been part of our
civilization.
And I'd be,
I'd be much more worried if people
stopped,
stopped asking these questions.
Yeah.
So for the people that are watching or
listening to this right now that still
have all the concerns about trump that
you may or may not have or,
or that you feel maybe are somewhat
deranged in terms of the conversation,
you've met the guy obviously a bunch of
times,
you know,
there's that one video when you guys had
that slightly awkward handshake.
Is there anything.
Well,
first I guess I have two parts to this,
one is do you have any regrets about
supporting him or speaking at the
convention?
And I want to talk a little bit more
about that in a minute also.
Um,
but also is there something that you can
impart on us that maybe we don't know or
that's not being told,
uh,
you know,
just from sitting down with the guy is
more stable than the way the media would
portray it or something along those
lines.
We certainly more or less
very smart and uh,
and it sort of a common sense intuitive
thing.
And so there's sort of a way that,
you know,
he can x Ray people and get an immediate
read on,
on somebody that's incredibly
impressive.
Yeah.
And so do you think there's a risk in
that also always relying on that
instinct as opposed to it's why,
you know,
they always are risks with these
things,
but that's,
that's,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a powerful ability.
And,
um,
and then,
uh,
and then there is a degree to which,
you know,
he has his ideas and um,
it's,
it's sort of,
he's thought these things through for
himself and uh,
and so the evidence that,
you know,
he's not as conformance does that,
is that the ideas are actually pretty
different.
You know,
it's,
you know,
is broken with the Republican Orthodoxy
on foreign policy.
You know,
there's um,
you know,
rethinking the immigration question,
rethinking the free trade questions and
um,
and these are,
these are,
these were like not,
not mainstream views at all,
pre 2016 and um,
and there is a way in which,
uh,
w what,
what I think has been even more
impressive than I would have expected is
the degree to which the debate has
shifted.
And so if we,
if we take the,
the,
um,
the debate about free trade,
you know,
the consensus in 2015 would have been
free trade is simply good in all times
in all places.
And if you don't understand that,
then you didn't study econ one and
you're,
you know,
you're a low Iq person.
End of argument and um,
and at this point it's much closer to
the,
you know,
there's obviously something just very,
very wrong with a lot of the trade
arrangements in the world and it's like,
uh,
you know,
we have,
uh,
we import $475,000,000,000
a year from China.
We export $100 million a year to China
and it's completely unbalanced and it's
actually not.
If we had a genuinely globalizing world
that's not the way it would look at all
in a globalizing world,
um,
the,
uh,
the less developed parts of the world
would grow faster and therefore capital
should flow to those parts and therefore
we should have a trade surplus with
China that we get extra capital that we
then export through.
In a way,
you're almost making a globalist
argument for him,
even though he's always against the
global a little differently.
So it's.
I would say that I would say that the
incredible trade imbalances tell us that
something's completely wrong with the
sort of pollyannish globalization story
were told of Chinese peasants saving
money and it's being sent upstream into
the slower growing us and even slower
growing Japan and western Europe and
it's all the money is flowing,
it's flowing in the wrong direction,
and that tells us something.
Then we can debate what do you do about
it,
you know,
do you escalate in order to deescalate
you?
Do how,
how do you rethink these things?
But uh,
but it's,
it's all,
it's all been opened up and I,
the prediction I would make is that
whoever the Democratic nominee in 2020
is,
they will not,
they will not disagree with trump on the
trade issue.
They won't admit the trump changed their
mind.
But this is one of the ways you win
debates is that,
uh,
people come around to your side and they
still say they never.
No.
It wasn't because of you.
That's how you really went.
Yeah.
It was that his really clever move
during the primary still where he kept
saying,
oh,
look how unfairly the DNC is treating
Bernie,
because basically he was hinting to all
of those people that were so frustrated
with the system when they screw him
over,
guess what?
I'm your guy.
It's not,
it's not hillary.
So it was a pretty,
pretty,
pretty clever little.
Typically they're all these,
all these things like this,
but I think,
I think it is,
it is just these other debates were a
country,
you know,
I think,
the question about NATO is,
is on the table now and once you put it
on the table,
uh,
you know,
why should the US be paying the lion's
share when we're actually mostly
defending these other countries.
It's not like NATO is on the southern
border defending us from Mexico.
Right,
right.
And you,
if you listen to the way the mainstream
media focusing,
it's always,
well,
trump wants to blow up NATO,
but that's not really what he said.
He said he wants other countries to pay
their fair share.
Those are very,
very different things.
Yes.
I mean,
they're,
they're link because you might say,
you know,
if you don't,
we're,
we might be willing to pull out if you
don't pay your fair share.
So it's not,
it's not like we're never going to
change.
But,
uh,
but certainly,
um,
certainly,
uh,
people,
nobody would disagree that everyone
should pay their fair share.
I want to talk to even people in
Germany,
which is like prompt,
maybe the most egregious offender of
all.
Nobody disagrees with this behind closed
doors.
So do you have any regrets?
I don't have any regrets about it.
You know,
I,
I would say that it,
um,
it certainly was,
it's been a crazier two years and I
would have thought and uh,
and I underestimated how,
you know,
how intense some of the feelings people
have about politics are,
but no regrets.
Yeah.
What do you make?
Just the general tenor then right now
that we sort of are between a rock and a
hard place where it's like you've got
trump and he's not going to change his
tactics.
And,
you know,
I think I've been very fair to him and
that's why I get a lot of criticism on
that front end and then you've got the
resistance or whatever you want to call
it,
that seems to be doubling down on a lot
of the bad ideas that got them there in
the first place and that both sides now,
or just splitting and splitting and
we're,
we're losing what I,
where I think most people are,
which is within some sort of basically
free society,
Libertarian live and let live thing.
I think I really believe that's where
most people are,
but we seem to be being pulled in in
opposite ways.
Well,
the way that we framed a little
differently,
I would say we're,
we're,
um,
we're moving past the Bush Clinton,
sort of do awfully.
And um,
and which was not exactly libertarian,
um,
it was pretty narrow,
pretty narrow zone.
There wasn't very much debate,
you know,
all the smart people supposedly agreed
on everything and it didn't work all
that well.
At the end of the day,
you know,
we had sort of a,
one,
one fake bubble in our economy after
another and um,
and it,
and,
you know,
it sort of got us into a lot of things
that,
that were,
were not optimal.
So,
uh,
so I think for the Bush Clinton maybe
also Obama years was 24 years.
The debate I would say was,
was,
uh,
was too narrow.
And I think within that sort of super
narrow center to center left debate in
this country,
uh,
you,
you're not going to find the solutions
to our problems.
It's gonna be it's gonna be way outside
of that.
And I think,
you know,
I think we will not go back.
You know,
we're not going to go back to Hillary
Clinton and 20 slash 20.
We're not going to go back to Jeb Bush.
Um,
and,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's going to be,
it's going to be a more wide open debate
and they're,
the parts of it that I don't like.
I don't.
I think,
uh,
I think the socialist question is going
to be on the table in ways that it
hasn't been for a long time and uh,
and I think I suspect the Democratic
Party is going to move much further to
the left and that's going to be a debate
we're going to be having for the next
decade.
I think they're wrong.
I think that's not gonna work,
but it's,
it's,
again,
it's the Clinton,
the narrow Clinton stuff.
I'm not going back to that.
Okay.
So one more thing on trump for now.
When you finally then came out,
so to speak and said,
all right,
I'm going to support trump.
Just personally,
do you feel like your cost,
you anything just,
you know,
friends,
family,
like,
or did you even care if that was going
to be the case because a certain amount
of people are going to go no matter what
you just said here about all the
legitimate issues related to trade and
government and all that they're going to
go,
he's racist and Ltl is racist or,
or something along those lines.
You know,
I don't,
I didn't cost me any friendships,
um,
and,
but the probably were,
there were,
there were some set of people that,
um,
you know,
where they were mad at me that had not
been mad at me before.
And,
you know,
that's unfortunate.
Uh,
I don't,
um,
you know,
I,
I didn't think it was that
controversial,
you know,
sort of,
I sort of like,
like in one,
in one way,
it was one of the least contrary of the
things I've ever done.
It was like half the country.
It's not that contrarian.
Right.
I've heard you say that the valley,
it felt really contrarian,
but,
um,
so that's,
that's sort of why you,
you're,
if you're doing something that half the
country agrees with you on that,
it's kind of weird for that to be beyond
the Pale.
I mean,
maybe it is,
that's actually hilarious,
least contrary and move in a way.
The least contouring thing I've done.
And so,
so,
uh,
it,
it's kind of,
um,
you know,
uh,
but,
but there is something about the
politics that's intense.
It felt zero sum for a long time.
Um,
and you know,
it is polarized.
It's extreme.
We don't know what the answers are.
And so there are,
there are ways that it's been,
um,
it's been weaponized that are,
that are not always,
not always healthy.
So I,
I,
uh,
you know,
I don't think we're going to go back to
the status quo ante unfortunately.
Fortunately or unfortunately,
that's just sort of gone with the wind.
So not we're not going back,
you know,
it's uh,
and it's,
it's quite possible we're gonna,
you know,
have sort of ever more intense politics
for quite some time in one of my
colleagues coined this term about a
decade ago that,
um,
you know,
something was John,
Jim Cramer,
the crazy person on CNBC.
He has this line where there's always a
bull market somewhere.
You have to just look for gift,
know where to find it.
And then the bull market,
uh,
my colleague suggested this was around
2008 that was getting started,
was a bull market in politics and which
is not a,
not necessarily a place where you want
there to be a bull market,
but,
uh,
but I think,
I think we are in this sort of bull
market in politics and uh,
and it,
it still has no end in sight and we're
going to be looking for,
um,
options that are further outside the
box.
And uh,
and the debate may be,
it may be even more intense the in the
years ahead than it has been.
It's been before.
Alright.
I think that's enough about trump for
now.
I have a feeling he'll probably appear
again,
but let's talk about sensemaking because
Eric Weinstein,
who I guess is the architect of the
intellectual dark web,
who is the,
what is his title?
He is the managing director of deal
capitals,
man of many hats.
A man of many hats.
Okay.
So one of the ideas that he has
discussed many times in this very studio
is that what's happening right now is
that our sensemaking or communal sense
making in America is just failing,
that our ability to trust the media or
CNN or New York Times or the rest of it
has failed to the point that this
intellectual,
dark web,
this crew of about 20 or so people,
uh,
are the last bastion of our ability to
just make sense of things or at least
try to make sense of things.
So I have a couple of questions on this,
but first Eric works for you.
You guys have major disagreements.
He was a Bernie guy.
You obviously supported trump a,
I'm sure he's been on these shows and
talked about probably policies that you
don't agree with and things like that.
Yet you let this guy do whatever he
wants.
I think that's a great credit to you,
but why?
Why do you do it?
I mean,
why do you let this guy run around and
do whatever he wants to do even when
it's in conflict with what you believe?
I don't think most people would do that.
Well,
I'm,
I'm interested in ideas always.
And I think that,
uh,
I don't think all the ideas are,
are just the conventional ideas.
I think there are.
I think that I think we need to find new
ideas,
new ways of approaching the world,
thinking about it.
And um,
and Eric is certainly absolutely first
grade,
heterodox thinker and uh,
and you know,
I don't think,
and I think all of our politics are
somewhat eclectic and somewhat complex
and you know,
and uh,
you know,
Eric is more on the left.
I'm more on the right,
but uh,
but,
uh,
we,
we both interested in ideas were
interesting to figuring out how to make
sense of our world and uh,
and that unites us and it's always
surprising how that's a pretty unusual
place to be there.
It's much of,
it's not about ideas.
It's,
as we said earlier,
it's about power or fashion or something
like that.
But,
but most guys in your position wouldn't
be allowing one of their top people to
be out there often taking positions that
are against them,
that there's something about you that's
allowing you to do that.
Right?
You know,
I,
I know you don't want to,
I know you don't want to sit here and
pat yourself on the back,
but I think it's an important piece of
something I think,
um,
and I'm not sure I'm right about this,
but let me go,
let me,
let me be a little bit more modest than
us,
but I think most,
most of my peers in silicon valley,
I think that the ideas are,
are more set.
We sort of know all the right answers
and it's inefficient.
It's a waste of time to be exploring
outside of that.
And,
and so the,
the sort of,
the substantive question you have to ask
is,
are the ideas right?
Or you know,
should we have more exploration?
So it's like,
you know,
you take the,
take the climate change debate,
there's,
there's a view that,
you know,
we know it's happening.
We are,
we go to the agenda.
We know that,
uh,
it's a runaway problem and um,
and uh,
and if we,
we can't,
we can't even pause and think about it
because we know all these things.
We have to just focus all our energy on,
on solving them.
And so if those things are true,
then that might be reasonable.
If they're,
if they're not entirely true,
like maybe you know,
maybe maybe climate change is maybe it's
more methane and carbon dioxide,
in which case maybe eating steak is
worse than driving a car.
So maybe maybe climate change is a
problem.
It's a little different from the way we
think it is.
And so if these things are not true,
then we need to have much more of a
debate.
And so the kind of question,
and that's very hard that you have to
make some judgment on us.
Do we more or less have the truth about
everything or don't we?
Yeah,
and my views that were really far off
and I think a lot of my peers think,
you know,
you were kind of at the end of history,
we sort of figured everything out.
There's,
we don't want to belong ideas,
we don't want to be an interesting,
weird ideas are just wrong and they're
just a waste of time.
And that's,
that's sort of their bias.
Mine's the opposite.
Yeah.
Do you think that this set of people,
and I think I would include you in that
in a broader sense.
I mean,
now you're sitting here and doing this,
um,
do you think we have a chance of
resetting some of this stuff?
I mean,
I think that just,
if you look in the last week,
I mean,
alon going on Rogan,
you're sitting down here again without
patting myself on the back from them.
Like I view that as like a landscape
change of the way people
that are influencers are visionaries are
reacting to media.
I think.
Yeah,
look,
I think,
I think the boxes are too narrow,
you know,
it's like,
it's like the baby boomer since 1968,
they'd been re litigating 1968 for 50
years.
We've had like the same fights.
They're getting kind of old,
but it's been been groundhog day for 50
years.
And,
um,
and,
uh,
and maybe there's something past
groundhog day and that's,
that's the bias you have bias I have.
And uh,
and I think part of it is I'm not just
talking about talking about ideas,
it's bringing forth some specific ideas.
These are things that are different,
that are changing,
that are,
you know,
that the world may look very different
in the future from where it looks in the
president.
But I think we're not at the end of
history.
We're not at a time where ideas don't
matter or people can't do things.
I think the future will be very
different from the present.
Maybe it's going to be better,
maybe it's going to be worse.
It's up to us.
And,
uh,
and so I'm,
I'm super long,
uh,
having a very broad conversation about
things.
Yeah,
I'm glad that you brought up the baby
boomers from omen because it does seem
like that partly what's happening here
is that they're at their last grasps of
controlling things.
And in an odd way,
gen x,
my generation got,
which I think you're probably right
around a little bit ahead of me on Gen
x,
that we sort of got lost.
And then we,
it's almost like we handed everything
off to the millennials,
but we didn't give them any of the tools
to be able.
They were too young and didn't have the
tools or the,
or the financial instruments to be able
to make any change.
Does that,
does that mean there are a lot of
strange generational dynamics one could,
one could talk about.
I had been very struck in recent months
and thinking about this,
how there is something very odd in terms
of what happened to gen x,
which is people born say 19,
65 to 1980 was the birth years.
Boomers were sort of 46 to 64 and,
and somehow,
you know,
the boomers dominated things like crazy.
And uh,
and there was,
we were sort of like in the shadow of
these people and all sorts of different,
uh,
in all sorts of different contexts.
And it was,
it was gen x was probably the first time
that you had a generation that was
smaller in numbers and the one that came
before us,
um,
you know,
it sort of coincided with an era of
slower growth,
slower progress.
So there was sort of fewer opportunities
to rise of baby boomers held onto their
positions.
And in some ways,
you know,
like when I,
when I started working in a law firm in
Manhattan in the early nineties,
I mean always,
I wasn't thinking of it consciously this
way,
but it was the baby boomer partners.
They just become partner and they were
sort of pulling the ladder up behind
them and it was going to be much harder
for people.
My generation,
our generation to do the same things,
to go down the track and the same in the
same way.
And so there is something,
there is something very weird about how,
how gen x
has gotten,
um,
you know,
has been sort of sidelined by the
boomers for so long.
And then the,
you know,
the wrap on us is always that we're,
we're too,
uh,
too young or too old.
Right.
And so we were in the nineties when gen
x was starting to tech companies.
We were seen as too young.
We needed adult supervision.
We needed the baby boomers to,
to run the companies.
That's an almost every gen x of founder
and some exceptions,
but overwhelmingly the boomers took over
the company.
There was a version this with Yahoo and
Ebay,
netscape,
even Google,
which was the biggest of the gen x
companies.
Uh,
you know,
you got a 10 year period where Eric
Schmidt,
the baby boomer took over,
took over Google.
Whereas the boomer companies,
apple,
Microsoft,
I'm a Amazon,
Microsoft and Amazon.
Amazon was just saying people got to run
the whole time.
And then apple,
a little bit more chaotic facebook
millennial company.
They got to run it.
Gen x not so much.
Do you think that tech is like
meritocratic?
It's not supposed to be about culture
and voting and stuff like this.
And then I think,
I think on a Po,
on a political level,
it's striking how underrepresented we
are.
A 20 slash 20 should be,
should be a prime year for a gen x
presidential candidate on the democratic
side,
someone born between 1965 and 1980.
And I challenge you to name me a single
plausible genex Democrat,
like a loser like Cory Booker,
right?
I mean that's the thing.
Well I think there's several reasons for
that on the democratic side,
but God depend on that.
Somehow
the boomers,
they're there more of them and so they,
they,
they look like it's truth in numbers and
it's the baby boomer bubble in a way.
It's always been that the numbers make
it right,
that if you have a lot of people it's
true and that's kind of what worked.
And so it in the boomers were this
unusually big generation and it was just
about them.
It just about getting consensus and then
you could overwhelm things and that's,
that's what you had to do.
And I think that's,
that's sort of coming to an end and
slowly I wonder,
do you think there's also just the flat
out technological component to this that
we ingenex we're the last generation
that grew up without all of this tech,
so I don't know what the exact
connection is,
but I remember being in college,
I think my freshman year I remember some
kid down the hallway screaming,
I'm on the Internet and I went into his
room.
I've told this story a couple times.
I went into his room and it said
Yankees,
three royals,
one and it had two pictures at a little
bit and I swear on my life I remember
thinking this is the stupidest thing
I've ever seen.
Like we did not grow up with the phones
in our pockets.
We didn't grow up connected all of those
things.
So it almost seems to me there's some
connection to that where then the
millennials came in,
they so connected
to all of this.
Then the media,
because the media wants clicks and
everything paid so much attention to
them that that may be pushed out gen x a
little bit more.
Do you think there's,
I'm just,
I'm just doing this cultural history.
It's always many variables.
Super overdetermined.
I,
I do think there's,
there's,
um,
there's something about the millennial
vibe that feels more conformist and gen
x feels less conformist.
And so,
uh,
and so one of the,
you know,
good and bad things about being overly
connected,
overly technologically connected is,
you know,
you get to get to know the score right
away.
You get the answer right away,
you know,
you're supposed to be scared of climate
change right away.
Um,
and that's good.
If it's true,
it's bad if it's a shortcut.
And so our generation,
you could say it was the last one that
didn't take shortcuts.
And most of the time the boomers learned
to take shortcuts.
We,
we didn't take as many shortcuts like
that.
Millennials have no to take all the
shortcuts and it's a good idea to take
shortcuts in a world where nobody takes
shortcuts.
I'm in a world where everybody takes
Um,
you know,
you have to actually figure out and
maybe the shortcut isn't going to work
and you're actually better off figuring
out the other thing.
Oh,
I love that.
So one way to frame this,
to be in the boomer era,
the boomers who figured out how to take
shortcuts,
a shortcut and politics is,
I'm not going to figure out what I think
about the issues I'm going to school.
Look at the polls and the pollsters,
the one who's really running for
president and just listening to the
pollster and that was,
that wasn't effective boomer technique
for many years that you just look at the
polls and if you were,
if you had a better pollster,
you could more quickly get to where the
puck was going,
where the crowd was going and you didn't
need to think.
You didn't have to waste time thinking
about stuff.
And so in a world where very few people
were doing it,
that can be a very good strategy.
By the time you get to something like
the millennials where everyone's been
trained to do shortcuts,
that somehow doesn't quite work.
It vaguely maps onto the tracking
because you can think of tracking and
school tracking professionally is a way
to.
It's like a shortcut to a successful
career and so the baby boomers who
stayed on track did quite well,
so if you didn't tune in,
drop out and the late sixties and it
just went to law school and you became a
partner at a law firm that it kind of
tracks worked.
By the time we get to the millennials,
they know all the tracks you're supposed
to do.
Tracks work less well when everyone
knows everyone.
Everyone's doing the same thing,
so it has sort of.
There are these similarities between the
millennials and the boomers,
but the lesson that they're,
they're,
they're really different in practice and
it's working really differently so that
the things that would have worked
perfectly for you as a boomer are deadly
if you're a millennial.
Yeah.
So,
okay,
so hearing that and
knowing that our sensemaking is breaking
down and our ability,
even our ability to just get away from
all of this,
what you said before about paying that
much attention to politics and all that.
Everyone asks the whole idw crew
constantly,
well,
what are you guys going to do?
And you just said something about,
you know,
we shouldn't just talk about these
things.
We got to do things.
Do you see either a technological answer
here or a business answer here or
something.
And we've talked about this a little bit
privately before and it's been kind of
bounced it around,
but like everyone wants some answers to
what's going on here with the media and,
and everything else.
And the pipes,
you know,
that Google owns all the pipes and all
of that stuff.
And I think a lot of people is a default
position is well too.
We'll fix it because it's like there's
only a couple people that actually
could.
Well it's,
it's,
um,
I don't,
I don't actually quite know what one
does to,
to fix the media industry.
I,
I would say the,
um,
the thing that I'm always super fixated
on is the business model questions zero
to one book.
Uh,
the,
the main motif has always,
um,
that you shouldn't compete.
You should try to have a monopolies,
tried to do something that you do so
well that you have no competition and
you know,
the good and bad things about monopoly.
But from the inside you generally want
to have a monopoly.
It gets a little bit bad if you become
too fat and lazy.
And um,
and if you didn't ever have competition,
you're really in trouble.
And you know,
in a way the business history I would
tell,
uh,
the mainstream media is that they used
to have great monopolies.
The newspapers had local content
monopolies and the local monopolies and
advertisers because the only way you
could advertise was through the
classified section of newspaper or news
magazines or you know,
they're all these sort of,
all these sorts of media monopolies.
And um,
what technology with the Internet has
done is it's opened things up in ways
that are good for information,
for,
for learning things,
but it's very bad for their business
models.
And I think this is something they never
really understood.
And so if you were,
if you were at the Washington Post in
the 19 nineties,
if you sort of imagine what the holiday
party would have been like,
um,
you know,
the,
the owner of the post would have said
something like,
you know,
we're all,
we're all getting paid,
you know,
we're doing great.
Business is doing great.
We have all these talented people that
are writing great stories.
And the narrative would be that it was a
great business because of the great
work,
the people there were doing.
And the true story was something like,
I know you're working for utility
company and doesn't matter what you do
because we'll,
we're gonna make these monopoly profits
year after year after year.
And then when the monopoly story started
to break the story was not the
monopolies going away because they can't
talk about that.
Right?
But the story was rather,
um,
we don't,
uh,
we don't know anything about the
internet or something like that.
And so I think,
I think the challenge that a lot of the
media,
old media businesses have haven't even
been described correctly.
And then it's,
but then it is,
you know,
it's sort of,
it sort of plays out in,
you know,
um,
in,
you know,
and,
and you have to figure out some new ways
to get distribution channels,
new ways to monetize and you know,
the are there.
I think there will be models for doing
that.
But that's the,
that's the question,
how to do it.
How do you,
you know,
you can't go back to the old monopolies
though.
Yeah,
we,
we need some answers.
All right.
Let's,
let's shift a little bit to some of
your,
some of your history because I think a
lot of people are a certain set of
people probably only know you through
the gawker prism and every time I read
anything about Gawker or what happened
with you or hulk Hogan it,
it always seemed so distorted the way
they presented it,
which is probably very obvious to you.
But to me it was like you weren't people
because people will say,
well teal hates the media.
He sued a publication.
He obviously hates the media and it's
like,
actually you were defending the right to
privacy,
which is something that the media should
be doing in and of itself.
Um,
what made you want to get involved in
this?
You had your own history with Gawker
obviously before.
Yes.
And all that it is,
you know,
there are all these elements of the
story that are of course,
you know,
sort of look a little bit larger than
life where you have sort of the
sociopathic,
uh,
um,
Manhattan media company and I think
that's kind of our,
our,
um,
our internal code name for Gawker was
the Mbta,
the Manhattan based terrorist
organization.
Well,
you've likened them to al Qaeda before
and then,
um,
uh,
yeah,
it was,
it was some crazy story in [inaudible]
where they just completely distorted
things.
And I was speaking to a reporter at the
San Jose Mercury News and like,
what do you think of them?
And I said,
oh,
they'll kind of silicon valley and say
that yes you can because of course you
get on.
But,
uh,
but the,
the,
uh,
and so I think they,
they were sort of this,
uh,
and it was in some ways you're all sorts
of things you can say about it were kind
of crazy and it was super destructive.
They went mostly they didn't go after
people like myself.
They went after people who were
relatively powerless,
often just average people,
not public figures in any sense of the
word.
Um,
you know,
Hogan was sort of an in between person
had been like a very high profile
celebrity,
but,
um,
was definitely,
it was definitely beating up on a weaker
person in a,
in a,
in,
in the context in which they did it.
So it had a,
it had this sort of heroic underdog
fighting this,
um,
this sort of hate factory.
He factory machine.
I bought her the right way to describe
it,
targeted at,
uh,
at various,
at various people.
Um,
you know,
um,
we have a first amendment and I believe
in,
I believe in freedom of speech.
Um,
you know,
and of course always,
the,
the Hogan trial,
although the,
you know,
the jury trial and the jury trial,
you can always argue the law.
We can argue the facts.
So the,
the,
uh,
the Gawker side argued the law,
which is,
you know,
we're,
there's a first amendment and it's
sacred and we're journalists and we get
to do whatever we want.
That's sort of.
And that was roughly their argument.
The Hogan side of it was you published a
sex tape that was secretly taken in the
privacy of a bedroom and those are the
facts that has nothing to do with the
first amendment.
It might have something to do with the
fourth amendment,
which is against unreasonable search and
seizure,
not just by government,
but also by private people obviously.
And um,
and uh,
and so,
you know,
and so yet,
is there a conflict?
Can there be a conflict between freedom
of speech and right to privacy probably
are cases where in theory there could be
conflict,
but this was one where it was simply a
violation of privacy.
And I would say it wasn't speech at all
and then,
you know,
are all sorts of like super agregious
facts that came out in trial,
you know,
one of the,
uh,
one of the reporters and the editors had
posted the sex tape and he,
uh,
he had a deposition with,
with the,
uh,
um,
it was a one day long deposition,
a few years before the trial.
And,
and,
uh,
it was,
you know,
sort of,
you have a lunch break,
come back after lunch.
Hey,
j Dilla area came back,
reeking of marijuana,
which,
you know,
not,
not against it,
but I would,
I wouldn't do it on your show.
I wouldn't do it.
Little of a legal deposition either.
And then,
um,
uh,
you know,
the Lord on our side as to is there any
sex tape you wouldn't publish little,
I guess it would involve the child.
And it was like,
what age child?
A four year old.
And so when you show that to the jury,
that's,
that's pretty devastating.
And so it,
it was one of these things where,
um,
you know,
I,
I thought that if,
if Mr,
if Terry Bollea Hulk Hogan,
if he ever had his day in court,
it was going to be a runaway effect.
It was going to be completely run away.
Um,
and uh,
and that's,
that's,
that's in effect,
what happened the last day of the trial.
Charles harder on,
he thought he thought that the largest
amount of money you could ask for with a
straight face was $100,000,000.
And then after seven hours the jury
comes back with 115.
And so it was just,
it was just,
it was just a runaway thing.
And it was,
maybe it was,
you can argue
that it was too much for this one
person,
but in some ways it was,
it was,
you know,
it was a million posts they've published
over the years that were,
that was what was really at stake.
Right.
Well,
I think a lot of people,
the people that,
that like you and defend you on this,
we'll say,
well,
this was a defense of free speech.
It was a defense of just the media
coming after everybody,
finding out anything you've ever done,
finding out any access to any picture
you've ever sent or any of that.
And we see the way this is sort of
infecting everything.
It's not that simple argument to make,
but the way I would argue is I think,
I think we need to have vigorous debate.
We need to have people with heterodox
views,
be able to articulate things and um,
and you know,
you can silence people by not letting
them speak,
but you can also silence them by if you
say something that's even slightly out
of line,
we're going to send the hate mob and
we're going to make up stories about you
and,
uh,
and personally destroy you.
And in a way that was the logic of the,
of the hate factory,
the scapegoating machine.
That was Gawker.
It,
uh,
you know,
in some ways the victims were picked at
random and in some ways they were not at
random.
In some ways they were the
nonconformists they were the people
with,
with views that were sort of heterodox.
I suspect that's one of the reasons
they,
they targeted me and again,
I was not targeted more than some other
people hurt even more than I was,
but uh,
but it was,
it was,
it was very often people who said things
that were just a little bit outside the
zone and then they were destroyed.
And the lesson was,
was one of silencing.
Yeah.
So we should talk a little bit about
them targeting you.
So they,
in effect,
they outed you,
right?
I mean,
is that where they officially the ones
that Audi?
Do you know?
I don't,
I don't.
I think even that history can be sort of
contested.
I mean,
I know you were out privately,
so I think it's hard to.
I think it was,
it was sort of somewhat in between zone.
Um,
they,
they targeted me repeatedly over year.
So it was,
it was that,
it was,
it was various other articles on the,
um,
and it was,
of course,
if we talk about outing,
it's,
it's never,
it's never a simply factual thing.
It's never,
Oh,
I'm Peter or David or gay.
Um,
Fyi,
it is.
Um,
it's more like a Peter Teal is gay and
we have no idea why he didn't want us to
talk about it and uh,
maybe it's because maybe it's because
his parents don't know and they'd be
embarrassed or maybe it's because he's
trying to get money out of Saudi Arabia
and uh,
and we don't really,
we don't really know why.
And so,
um,
so outing is always the way it worked.
I think it happens actually much less,
but the way it worked,
I'm always involved a description of
someone's sexual orientation and a
description of how psychologically
messed up they were,
right?
Because they didn't want you to write
the article.
And the way I think our society has
progressed is that the word we have for
outing today is something like bullying.
And the question is shifted from the
psychology of the person being written
about to the psychology of the writer.
And the question is why would you,
why would you do something as nasty as
this?
And so there was.
So that's a pretty powerful.
It's been a very big cultural shift.
So in 2007,
when they,
um,
when they went after me outing was still
acceptable in 2015 they went after the
cfo of Conde Nast.
Um,
and,
you know,
again,
sort of who knows the story was even
true,
right?
But,
um,
uh,
but,
the response was,
well,
that's an incredibly vicious thing.
Why are you a reporter?
So vicious,
why are they so hateful?
What's wrong with you to be.
It was sort of like linked to bullying,
high school,
bullying,
all,
all these,
all these kinds of phenomena.
So,
so we.
So I think,
I think,
uh,
I think things,
you know,
I think we have actually progressed,
transparency doesn't always mean that
you make things better.
It's,
it's sometimes it's just,
it's just,
you know,
it's just an excuse for,
for attacking people.
Do you think that in your case that it
was also directly linked to your
politics?
Because if you had been the exact same
person,
you are with the exact same resume and
it created the exact same companies,
but you had been a lefty,
you had been playing ball the way that
they want you to play ball,
that why would they try to harm you?
I mean,
in effect they were trying to harm you
one way or another.
I think that's why they,
they do these things.
That's why the,
the label bully is applicable here.
That to me it's like,
well,
he's the libertarian.
He some scary anti government guy.
So how can we get him?
Well,
it's Adam.
Do you think that's a fair estimation?
You know,
it's,
it's probably a factor.
It's hard to know.
I think.
I think on some level we were just
trying to get paged.
Clothes just sounded.
I mean,
I,
you know,
it's,
um,
we're still,
I think you're being too charitable to
them in a way because you're giving them
an ideological motive and you're saying
they were these principled leftwing
people who went after,
uh,
the bad,
right wing power structure that is a
principled.
But yeah.
Um,
and I think they weren't even,
they were more nihilistic than liberal
or left wing and um,
and you know,
you could,
you could dress up the nihilism.
We're going to blow somebody up,
we're gonna do some crazy,
um,
attack on some random person and we're
going to try to give it some thin
ideological gloss.
But I think it was just,
it was just a,
it was,
it was like,
it was run as like this crazy sweatshop
where,
you know,
the,
uh,
the people were paid very little and
they were paid based on how many clicks
they got.
And so you had to come up
with crazy sensational headlines and
then stories that uh,
you know,
sometimes had a relationship with the
truth and sometimes didn't.
Yeah.
And that has really permeated the
internet altogether.
Now,
I mean,
if I look every week,
you know,
I'm on tour with Jordan Peterson.
It's like every morning I wake up and
it's like somebody writes something
awful about him that I know is not the
truth.
And it's like they have every interest
in doing it because he will defend
himself bus driving clicks.
Oh,
I know,
I will still say that I think gawker was
in some ways a singularly sociopathic
bullies and uh,
and it is true that there's a lot of
stuff like,
would you characterize,
I don't think,
I think people discounted more.
It has less impact.
I think,
you know,
in its heyday,
gawker had impact because they were,
they were sociopathic,
they were bullying and people didn't see
it yet.
And that's,
that's the devastating kind if you're,
if you try to bully someone and
everybody says right away you're a
bully,
you might still be a bully,
but not as not.
You're not gonna be that effective.
If you're bullying people say,
oh,
this is just the Internet,
this is Tuck,
this is the future.
You're going to have cart wash.
And so gawker had carte blanche for many
years to destroy people in a way that I
think has gotten much less effective.
I mean,
it still happens.
They're still,
you know,
you can have the hate mob form on
twitter,
the sort of still versions of this.
But,
uh,
it's,
it,
it's much less generative.
All right,
so let's,
let's talk about sexuality for a little
bit because this isn't something that
you talk about that often.
We,
we've talked about it privately a little
bit.
Um,
well,
first off,
you're married,
congratulations.
You got married in the last year.
How much of your sort of contrary in
view of the world,
just the way you see things differently
do you think is linked to be engaged?
Because before just the last couple of
years where I think being gay has been
so attached to leftism gay used to mean
fun or different or politically
incorrect and making edgy jokes and,
and being at subversive clubs are all of
these other things,
whatever it was a and gains were really
about the individual.
That was the whole point.
I'm,
you now are sort of,
as I said at the top,
kind of the ultimate contrarian and I
wonder is there a link between that and
sexuality,
do you think?
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't want to exaggerate and he's,
and he's such link.
Um,
and I think,
you know,
I,
I think of myself as like,
there were sort of,
I'm always bad at or biography
yourselves,
start that fire,
but I always think of myself as somehow
I was both.
I'm a total insider and a total
outsider.
So it was like,
you know,
straight a student,
on,
on the elite university elite law
school,
elite law firm track.
Um,
you know,
it was a bit of a nerd.
I was um,
you know,
I was uh,
I was born
in Germany,
immigrant to theu ,
uh,
um,
you know,
the gay thing.
So all these,
all these ways that I was both an
outsider and insider and probably
there's some way,
some way,
all this stuff,
you know,
summed up to,
to um,
make me less,
less prone to just believing in the
received wisdom.
But I know I,
I wouldn't,
I would certainly not want to say
anything remotely like that,
that gay people have a privileged access
to the truth or,
or anything like that.
That's that,
that seems kind of crazy.
Okay.
So a couple of years ago you go to the
Republican National Convention and uh,
you talked about being gay,
which had always been an Athema over
there.
What,
what was the exact line that you had
said?
Well,
it was a,
I'm proud to be gay.
I'm proud to be a republican,
but most of all I'm proud to be an
American.
And uh,
and so it was,
uh,
it was,
it was.
And so I think it functioned in both a
way that,
uh,
you know,
every American has an identity.
It's a,
it's not something we should ignore or
totally diminish and we should not make
it all important.
And it was sort of trying to steer a
certain,
you know,
middle course on,
on,
on identity politics where,
you know,
it's,
uh,
I think it's very easy to go too far in
one direction or another.
You can even say that you know,
that all identity is fake.
It doesn't matter.
It's all made up.
And that's,
I think that's wrong.
I think there was an African American
experience,
there's a female experience,
there's a gay experience and they are,
they are different.
And then,
um,
and then of course there's,
you know,
an equally bad mistake of,
of,
of making it all important,
uh,
where,
you know,
that's all there is,
that's what defines you.
And then it ends up becoming more of a
straight jacket.
So,
you know,
the gay,
the gay metaphor that I've used is that,
you know,
um,
you can be in the closet,
you can be in the ghetto and there,
those are mutually exclusive,
but I hope they're not exhaustive,
but something in between.
Right.
Because those two are pretty good.
Something that's neither,
neither of those two.
Yeah.
So when you said that would be the
closet,
I don't want to be in the ghetto.
Yeah.
So when you said that line and then got
bad ovation,
first off,
were you,
were you nervous to say that line
because that's no small feat just to
have it in the speech and ready to go.
Here's your nervous to speak,
you know,
it was just,
it was like speaking to 50,000
people or whatever.
It's kind of a strange super adrenaline
type experience.
But that particular line,
I mean,
when you got the applause and there
must've been some party that was like,
it worked like,
or,
or something has changed or something,
you know,
I again,
I don't think,
I don't think the Republicans are that
anti gay.
They don't think of that antibiotic.
And I mean,
I think maybe maybe they were in the
past,
uh,
but,
but it was,
it was clear that this was not the
issue.
This was not the hill they wanted to die
on in 2016.
And so somebody had to say it.
Yeah.
So unless I,
it,
you know,
it felt a little bit risky,
but I don't even want to exaggerate
that.
I think,
I think it would have been a very crazy
thing to say 20 years earlier.
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's shift to some new ideas.
How about,
how do you feel about that?
Absolutely.
Through some new ideas.
So seasteading is one of the things that
you've been interested in for years.
This idea that we're going to basically
create in effect states that are going
to be on platforms in the sea that I
think are sort of going to be
libertarian utopias,
or at least that would be the general
idea.
It seems like it had a lot of momentum
behind it for awhile.
Then kind of went away.
I think there's some renewed interest in
it now.
What got you interested in this and
well,
where's it at now?
It,
um,
it was,
uh,
Milton Friedman.
I sort of knew Milton Friedman a little
bit and his grandson pot Patri Friedman.
I'm like,
someone got in touch with and um,
and he was super.
He sort of spearheaded this seasteading
idea probably about a decade ago now.
And it was sort of a creative,
different,
interesting idea.
You know,
I gave it a small amount of funding.
It wasn't one of the things I did that
much with,
but it,
it's somehow an incredible nurse.
And so,
um,
and I think it's,
and it hits such a nerve because I'm in
this idea of starting a new country or
doing something new.
It reminds people that,
uh,
if we had to design a country from
scratch,
we designed the state of California from
it will be so different.
And um,
you know,
there's all these sort of super corrupt
governance institutions we'd clean out
and we'd,
uh,
you know,
um,
and um,
and so it's a,
you know,
I'm not sure I called Utopian,
but it's a,
it's a thought experiment that,
uh,
that,
gets that energizes people and gets them
to think about things.
I spoke at this,
I'm free market university in Guatemala
years ago and um,
uh,
they told me that the,
they had free speech on everything,
but the one thing that you weren't
allowed to speak about were things like
seasteading or scarring countries reason
you weren't allowed to speak about them,
was that if you started people to talk
about anything else and it's because,
um,
it's because it's,
it's always such a,
such a powerful hook and you know,
there are questions about whether it
will be allowed.
So you have to sort of get probably
some,
some local promotion.
There's a question on how
technologically feasible it is.
Um,
there's sort of a pilot program that
they're working with French Polynesia
and starting,
it's still somewhere in the,
in the intermediate stage,
but,
uh,
yeah,
you can see perhaps seeing if you can
get,
if you can get political autonomy,
the assumptions you would do things that
are very different.
I do medical tourism.
You might do,
you know,
that might be all sorts of offshore
banking.
You can do all kinds of that one might
be able to do differently and um,
and the,
you know,
the link to a link to,
to,
um,
to technology that,
uh,
you know,
I mean I think he's a,
you let a lot of these different micro
states bloom and you'd sort of see what
would come out of.
But the specific technological,
scientific,
technological thing that I think could
come out of some new political
arrangements at some point is always
this question whether we could get new
medicines,
new drugs,
um,
you know,
could you have something where you use
psilocybin or MDM as an antidepressant
drug or can you get,
can you get new?
Um,
can you get a new medical treatments
through where you sort of break the FDA
monopoly on,
on medicine worldwide?
So basically you would see all of these
different units sort of having different
rules that they live by,
kind of as an experiment to see what
would work is that,
that's,
that's one level.
But then the specific thing that I would
say the general abstract hold,
the specific thing that I,
I would hope would come out of it would
be more scientific and technological
progress that's too heavily regulated by
the heavy hand of our existing state and
that there are all these things we can't
do.
So there's all sorts of things of
governance might be better.
It might have different penal system or
don't have millions of people who are
incarcerated.
There are all sorts of things one might
do very differently.
The specific one that I,
that I'm probably most tracked who's
this is this question of whether we can
do new biomedical things.
Yeah.
So we could do three hours just on this,
but it's only one more question on this,
which is,
how do you decide who gets in on this?
How do you decide who can,
who can live there,
who can be part of this?
I mean,
this is purely a financial move.
If you've got enough money,
you're good to go.
Or do you,
are you trying to build a society and
picking all sorts of other people and
all of those things get you had to make
all these decisions,
get to make these decisions,
you get to make these decisions.
And that's uh,
and uh,
that's.
But I think that's always,
that's always sort of one of the
foundational decisions in the society
who,
who's part of it,
how do we define it?
And um,
and you know,
it's,
it can be unfair and oppressive if,
um,
if you have just one society and if
you're not in it,
you're nowhere.
But if you have,
if you have many of these places,
that's very different.
Yeah.
And so the pushback on this is then that
somehow this means you don't like
America or something like that,
which is I,
uh,
no,
but I,
I,
I certainly think that if we have
competition governance,
we,
we could,
we would do a lot better.
Yeah.
All right,
so let's talk.
Let's move ahead.
So a flying cars a lot is against them.
Now.
He's building an underground tunnel in
this very city where he out on the fly
of cars these days because we had a,
we had the,
it was a tagline
we had on our,
um,
on our venture capital,
uh,
website,
um,
you know,
they,
they promised us flying cars and all we
got was 140 characters sort of.
We've got to 80 now.
And um,
and so it was,
it was,
uh,
it was more a commentary on,
um,
on a technology that we were promised
these massive breakthroughs that would
transform the way the world works.
And then we got sort of incremental
communication technologies but not,
not world transforming.
And so I do think flying cars will be,
you know,
would be a good thing.
I know,
I think Ellen's objection was they were
too,
too noisy and then of course the
question is can you design them so
they're not so noisy?
So there's always sort of what are,
what are the actual limits on,
on the technology,
but the um,
but the sort of iconic for can we have a
Jetson's future?
Can we have a future where things look
really different?
And the striking thing is that we live
in a world that doesn't look that
different from the 19 eighties.
Again,
the,
you know,
we're,
we're looking at screens,
we're distracted by our iphones all the
time,
but the iphones that distract us from
our environment also distract us from
the way in which our environment
strangely hasn't changed.
We're running maybe writing a 100 year
old subway in New York City or you know,
the um,
the zoning laws mean that the cities
like San Francisco looked like they
haven't changed in 50 years.
Not that technologically advanced San
Francisco is getting so expensive.
You had to leave.
I mean,
that's not the precise reason,
but,
um,
but it basically,
uh,
so it's sort of like,
can we,
can we have more technological progress
than we have?
And uh,
you know,
it's,
it's uh,
the,
the um,
the sort of iconic image.
I always have this,
you had the two back to the future
movies,
the first one,
they went from 85 to 1955 and things had
changed a lot from 1955 to 1985.
The second one,
they went from 1985 to what they thought
2015 would be like,
and you're going to have like,
I mean,
all it was going to like this crazy
different world.
And I think the reality is the world of
Twenty 15,
uh,
looks much less different from the world
of 1985 and 85 was from 55.
So waiting for that hoverboard.
What happened to the hover ball?
All these kinds of things.
Yes.
And so it's,
uh,
and so there is sort of this,
this,
and I think that,
you know,
one of the,
one of the ways our society works,
one of the ways liberal democracy or
representative government works is that
you have a scientific technological
progress going on in the background.
You have growth,
the pie is growing.
If the pie grows,
we can find creative ways to,
um,
to shift the pieces that everybody gets
more.
Um,
when the Pi stops growing,
when there is no progress,
then you end up with this polarized
world with the zero sum politics.
Know for every winner there's a loser.
Anyone who succeeds is suspected of
being part of some kind of a racket or
something.
And,
um,
and so I think I,
I think there is actually a pretty,
uh,
um,
there's a link pretty deep link between
this,
uh,
the question of scientific and
technological progress and,
uh,
the health of our sort of representative
democracy.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
that's a good segue to,
to Ai,
because we've talked about this a little
bit and you've told me something once
that I,
I,
I'm actually not sure if you've said
publicly,
but I think it's pretty on point that
basically if you're an authoritarian,
you should be for ai and libertarians
are sort of against the.
I am I,
am I getting that roughly correct?
Yeah.
I think the best sound bite was on
Bitcoin if crypto is libertarian than ai
as communists.
So everyone thinks of crypto is
libertarian because you have all these
ideas about decentralizing money and
things like this.
Nobody says ai is communist and that's
because we're sort of,
we're more conscious of people with
different views like libertarian and
were less conscious of people with
collectivist views because that's sort
of the,
that's more the Zeitgeists but uh,
but yes,
I think ai crypto versus ai dichotomy
goes to the sort of question,
what's the future of the computer age
going to look like?
And,
and is it going to be more centralized
or more decentralized?
We hit that thing about the history.
We've had these very different pictures.
So you know,
in the late sixties,
the early star trek episodes you had,
maybe it was one planet,
they got to where there was one big
computer that ran the whole planet had
been running it for 8,000
years and people didn't have any
thoughts.
They're all sort of docile,
kind of happy.
Nothing ever happened.
And that was what people thought the
future would be.
In the late sixties when we centralized
big computers,
the late nineties it was going to be
crypto,
it was going to be decentralized,
the Internet was going to split up all
these sort of structures and that was
like 1998,
let's sort of let's say 68 with
centralized,
98 was decentralized 2018.
In some ways the pendulum has swung back
to centralize this big governments,
big databases that can monitor and
survey people and know more about you
than you know about yourself or things
like that.
Sort of creepy big brother type thing.
But I think,
I think since the pendulum has swung
back and forth so much over the last 50
years,
there's no reason that that's the
future.
It's actually a choice.
Do we want it to be centralized?
Do we want it to be decentralized and
what,
what I think ai can mean many different
things,
but if it means that you have large
databases that are controlled by,
let's say,
a large government that can monitor
people more effectively,
it's something that could make communism
maybe more effective,
certainly more scary,
more totalitarian than it ever was in
the 20th century.
And the,
I do think,
and it's not a coincidence along
these lines that the Chinese Communist
Party hates crypto and won't say ai and,
and again,
you know,
they,
ai means something a little bit
different.
What it means in a silicon valley
context.
We're in silicon valley.
Ai Off
just means,
you know,
a,
um,
a super smart computer that will leave
all the humans behind in China.
It means a,
a,
a
really smart computer that helps a few
humans control the rest.
Yeah.
So it almost seems like we're going to
splinter off into two versions of this
where we'll have these two tracks
that'll be side by side.
Half the people are really going to be
into this sort of centralized idea of
things and the ease that ai will allow
you to get products or whatever else it
is.
And then you'll have this other group of
people who maybe who are into all the
cryptocurrencies and all that who are
just sort of,
I don't know,
I suppose are operating outside of the
system or something like that.
It's,
you know,
I,
I think it's,
um,
it's,
it's possible these things can be
overlapping,
but it's also possible can go much more
one way or the other that it can be
ultimately that the future can be more
decentralized,
are more centralized,
it can be more capitalists,
more communist,
more libertarian,
more totalitarian.
So,
um,
so I think it can go and,
you know,
a lot of different ways and it's an
info.
This is why these debates are important
because it's up to us to decide which
technologies do we push and which ones,
you know,
are we,
are we maybe,
you know,
I'm going to be a little more careful
and I think you should outlaw ai are
regulated.
But,
uh,
but I think that,
um,
that,
uh,
that uh,
the certainly are other technologies
that I would like to do better,
so I know you're not in the well,
what are some of those technologies or
something like the mainland,
the contrast example?
Yeah.
So I know that a huge percentage of my
audience just because they know all the
craziness I've been through with
demonetization and I'm always
complaining about the algorithm and our
video's not going to feeds and all of
these things and that we've just sort
of,
we just don't know what's going on.
You know,
and you know,
my feelings on this about I don't want
the government telling these companies
what to do,
but I would like a little more
transparency out of the,
out of the government.
I'd like to know what's Kinda going on
with the algorithms and things like
that.
Is there any way we could know more
about these algorithms and things that
are giving us all this information?
Or is that just there's reasons why we
can't know all of that?
I'm not even sure if I framed that
question correctly.
No,
look,
I'm sorry.
I always have to be careful here since
I'm on the board and,
and
um,
and I,
I,
I certainly think that,
um,
uh,
in my judgment,
um,
you know,
facebook has been given a bit more of a
bum rap than it deserves on,
on,
on many of these scores.
But,
but I,
I would say that,
uh,
that I think,
um,
there is this,
this question is going to continue.
It's a,
it's,
you know,
does silicon valley discriminating
against certain voices?
Is it um,
or the algorithms in fact neutral or are
they coded
to discriminate against conservative
libertarian voices that are out a little
bit outside the mainstream.
And I think Silicon Valley is making a
mistake if it thinks that that question
can be sort of swept under the rug and
this is going to go away,
I think.
I think the question is going to be
asked with,
uh,
with,
you know,
more intensity in the years ahead and I
think people are either going to have to
answer it.
Yeah.
All right.
So two more for you.
Did you ever think if 20 years ago
someone would have said to you,
you know,
teal in 2018,
you're going to leave silicon valley and
not only you're going to leave silicon
valley,
you're going to go to la for freedom.
You know what I mean?
You're going to go to La to escape,
to find some free thinkers.
Now there's something interesting
happening in La Right now and it goes to
something that you referenced earlier.
Politics and media are sort of becoming
one thing and there is suddenly this new
home here have kind of free thinkers
that are interested in politics and all
that,
but the fact that you ended up here of
all places where this is thought of as
Hollywood and the liberal lefty elite
and all that stuff,
does that seem crazy to you that of all
places you're going to end up here now?
I know that way.
I don't think it would have predicted it
20 years ago.
Certainly.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
you know,
I think there's a lot of different
reasons when a chooses to live in place,
probably like bigger cities is something
that is sort of a lot,
a lot of things you can do in big cities
you can't do.
And in smaller places.
One of the,
one of the things that our is a very
different field between Los Angeles and
Silicon Valley.
Is that a Los Angeles is,
it is a weirdly,
it is the big city that is weirdly
decentralized and it doesn't have a
center.
Um,
you know,
people always complained about how bad
the traffic is.
But uh,
one of the virtues of it is it's somehow
it isn't.
It isn't like this,
uh,
this intense manic,
a bubble like Manhattan or like a San
Francisco in silicon valley have become.
And so,
um,
the superintendent's network effects you
have in Manhattan,
and I'm in Silicon Valley can be very
positive because it's like you sort of
communicate things,
you get ideas,
but then at some point you get a tipping
point,
gets crossed.
Where it goes with,
becomes more negative,
becomes group think loving like
behavior.
The Madness of crowds and uh,
and my judgment is somehow a silicon
valley's,
you know,
jumped the shark just a little bit over
the last few years that,
uh,
that,
the very things that were positive got
pushed so far till they actually became
poisonous.
Yeah.
Do you think you get more support
privately from some of your colleagues
then?
Maybe publicly on something like that?
Like where people,
other ceos calling you and going to,
you know,
I get it too.
I'm having trouble hiring qualified
people because of all of.
Oh,
absolutely.
There's,
there's an economic look,
the whole bunch of reasons.
There's the,
you know,
the,
um,
the reductionist economic reason that
things have gotten less desirable.
Silicon Valley has gotten
too expensive.
If it's $2,000
for one bedroom apartment,
maybe that's like a boom town and that's
showing things are going well.
If it's $4,000,
that's like just a crazy tax that maybe
should think twice about paying.
And so,
um,
so yes,
I think that,
uh,
yeah,
even on the nuts and bolts,
if you're,
if you're starting a new company,
um,
you know,
five,
six years ago it was clear and tech that
silicon valley was the right place to do
it because of all the network effects
and more capital and more talent.
And that sort of helped today I think
it's much more ambiguous.
It doesn't mean it's all going to move
to la or move some other place.
I think.
I think it's gonna be much more
decentralized.
Um,
you know,
one of the very strange ironies or
paradoxes of the Internet age that it
was supposed to,
the Internet was supposed to eliminate
the tyranny of place.
And,
um,
and that it all was,
almost all of it happened in this,
uh,
in this narrow silicon valley area.
You know,
there was a.
remember there's a talk I gave at
Stanford University or a panel
discussion in two back in 2005.
And one of the questions was where will
we find the next google?
So it was a student audience,
the student union at Stanford and was
sort of a and so they were interested in
working for the next Google company.
So it was a search problem searching for
the next Google can't type into the
Google search engine,
but it's really valuable to figure it
out.
And I sort of thought it sort of clever,
slightly crypt against I gave was,
you know,
I think there's a 50 percent chance the
next google is within a five mile radius
of this room.
So it's,
I'm narrowing the search problem.
Five mile radius was about maybe roughly
a millionth of the surface area of,
of,
of the resource,
reducing it by a factor of a million.
The problem still pretty hard.
A lot of garages and things you have to
look at within a five mile radius.
And I think that was actually right.
It was that concentrated.
So the next Google was facebook and it
was one point eight miles from that Rep.
and so,
you know,
I didn't realize it at the time,
but that was,
it was correct.
If I had to give the same speech today,
it would be,
it would be a way less than 50 percent
within 50 miles.
Wow.
And so I think,
I think it is going to be much more
decentralized.
So you have the consensus has total
centralization and just as with ai and
Crypto,
I'd be more in the crypto than the Ai
side in general.
I'd be much more on the decentralization
then centralization side.
So I know you haven't been here for that
long,
but do you think that there's been any
costs that you maybe didn't expect like
that there's something going on?
They're still,
there's some still still some spark of
something that maybe you won't have
access to enough or be around as much or
something like that.
You think there's any risk there?
You know,
I think,
I think I'll have access to the same,
the same sort of things,
but I think,
I think,
I think it's just getting a little bit
the outsider perspective.
Healthy.
Yeah.
You know,
and uh,
and you know,
when we,
when we initially set up my office,
we were in San Francisco,
which was a little bit outside of
Silicon Valley for many years.
So I'm,
so I always think you want to be,
you want to be,
um,
you know,
you want to be not in the middle of the
insanity.
You don't want to be totally in the
boonies,
want to be somewhere in between and a,
and I don't,
I don't think la is totally in the
boonies.
Well where I live by being.
All right.
Um,
okay.
So one more for you.
So,
you know,
I've been on this tour with Jordan
Peterson for the last couple of months
and you know,
um,
it's so interesting because I go online
all day and there's people yelling at
each other and seemingly hating each
other.
And then I spend my nights with
thousands of people who are coming
together over ideas who may disagree on
this or that but really want to find
some answers.
So as someone,
one of the few people now that I think
is trying to find answers that is
actually making sense,
that,
that really wants to look at different
ways to solve the problems of the day
for the young people that are watching
this take anyone under 30 that's
watching this and wants to feel hopeful
because that's the other part that I
think is changing.
There's a huge amount of people that
don't feel hopeful for the future.
They feel our political establishment is
just at,
uh,
at odds they feel this constant hate
online.
For those people that want to feel
hopeful,
what do you,
what can you give them that they can
look to for a hopeful future?
Well,
it's,
it's always hard.
It's always really hard to give,
you know,
it's always really hard to give generic
advice and I not going for generic and
always,
I always feel so many things you can say
that just sounds like bs in a way.
And that's sort of why this is actually
a simple but difficult question.
A very hard question away.
I think,
um,
you know,
the autobiographical part,
I,
I tell about my history was that I was,
I was super tracked,
you know,
it's like eighth grade junior high
school yearbook,
one of my friends says,
you know,
I know you're gonna get into Stanford
and four years,
four years later you get into Stanford
to get into Stanford law school.
I ended up at a top tier law firm in
Manhattan and it was,
you know,
when these places on the outside,
everybody wanted to get in on the
inside,
everybody wanted to get out and um,
and the sort of,
sort of a quarter life crisis.
I didn't never had a midlife crisis but
had maybe a quarter life crisis in my
mid twenties and the quarter life crisis
was,
um,
you know,
why did I end up in this,
what did I do?
And I think it was that I,
I just followed the track and I wasn't
thinking about,
you know,
why I was doing things,
what I was doing.
And,
and,
and I think that's,
that's sort of,
that's the generic advice is that um,
the tracks are not working.
Maybe they,
maybe they worked,
they worked better in the past,
they had problems,
but they work better.
They worked,
they stopped working for Gen x,
they're working even less for
millennials or Gen z who,
or whatever's next.
And it's,
it's,
um,
and so it's more important than ever to,
to think for yourself to find something
you're good at,
you're interested in,
you're motivated at and,
and do it.
The,
um,
you know,
the,
again,
the generic,
the somewhat will actually cross the
board.
Advice I always have is not to be overly
competitive that the,
you know,
the tracks forced you to compete,
you compete,
you win,
you cycle and repeat and uh,
and you need to find something where,
you know,
you're not always just looking at the
people around you and you have some,
some other reference point.
Um,
you know,
this is sort of more of a,
of a,
of a religious cut on this.
But,
uh,
I'm always struck by how,
um,
you know,
the 10 commandments there,
they're sort of a,
they're kind of the first and last and
some or maybe the,
the important ones at the,
at the end,
and one's the first one is you should
only look to God.
There's only one God and worship him.
And then the last one is you shouldn't
covet anything that belongs to your
neighbor or,
and so,
uh,
that you shouldn't look at the people
around you too much.
And um,
and so we need to find some way to look
up,
to look,
uh,
not to look around because when we look
around it,
it's a,
it's not that we figured out what we
want to do is just ends up being the
hyper copycat,
the medic crazed environment.
And that's.
So it's always,
there needs to be more of a,
you need to find some transcendence.
I think this is,
this is what,
this is,
what's powerful about the Peterson
message.
It's that it can't just be fashion.
It can't just be what everybody thinks
because that's just a,
you're gonna.
You're just going to be competing with
people like crazy.
Yeah.
There's a literal metaphor here and that
we're always looking down on our phones
while you're telling us to look up.
Yeah,
we don't,
but we were always.
We're looking too much at the people
around us and we're,
you know,
and,
uh,
and it's,
it can be efficient,
it can be a shortcut and then at some
point it can just be a trap because,
you know,
it's,
it's like the,
you know,
the business school example I often
give,
were you thinking of a business,
Harvard business school or any of these
business schools as hothouse
environments,
which you have a bunch of people,
they have no transcendent reference
point.
They,
they,
uh,
they have no idea what they want to do.
They're all sort of extroverted.
They'll spend two years talking to each
other about what to do.
They don't have any ideas and there's
almost a dynamic where you end up with
a,
the most faddish that and the most wrong
idea being the consensus choice for,
uh,
for so many of these people.
And that's,
that's always a dynamic to try to avoid.
Yeah.
I don't know how to end an interview
better than that.
I'm,
I'm so glad that we finally got to do
this.
You know,
I was thinking before I sat down with
you,
where do I point people to with Peter
Teal and I can point them to your and
everywhere else.
But then I thought,
you know what?
The guy's only tweeted once and that's
probably the best place I could point
people to because these days everyone's
fighting on twitter and you only tweeted
one time.
So I look at the camera,
follow Peter on the twitter at Peter
Teal,
unless you want me to point them
somewhere else.
That's okay.
Pleasure my friend.
Thank you very much.
All right,
thanks a lot.